Well, good morning, everybody.
Oh, my gosh.
I feel so well rested today because I passed out after the
Mademoiselle.
I think I slept, like, at least 15 hours yesterday.
I remember, like, making my waiting room, and then I was
out.
I was just, I'm gone.
Oh, my God.
I was so tired.
I think I needed to, like, catch up sleep from Tokyo.
me in Avcon as well because I don't think I slept as much as
I would like after the conventions there and then like after
Madonna stream I just was like I'm gone I'm out I was like
I'm gonna take a nap and then I get some work done but also
because I um because I slept uh really early on I didn't get
any work done after the stream so my staff was like uh Doki
we really need you to finish this up And I'm like, I'm
sorry, I just, I'm sorry, I just woke up.
I was like, I'm sorry, I took a nap and it ended up
sleeping.
I know I said I was going to get it done yesterday.
I'm sorry, I'll get it done today after Sandland.
I know it could be an endurance stream today because I'm
playing Sandland till completion.
But like, I swear, I swear I'll get started.
I'm sorry, but, but don't keep your clock.
Oh my God, fucking bureau clock.
Hey, welcome to the main farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh my gosh.
Yesterday was fucking wild.
What a, what a, I still can't believe we, everybody lived.
Everybody lived and then bureau clock came, came in with a
steel chair.
I even foretold it.
I was like, man, I swear to God, if we, if Julia just, dies
because of beer o'clock.
I swear to fucking guy.
Beer o'clock.
Um.
Oh, anyway.
If you guys didn't know, the PAL World VOD is back.
Um, with the chat fixed.
I have no idea what the fuck happened with the PAL World
stream.
Because, like, it got the chat for it was, like, broken.
And for, like, a couple of days and then they took down the
stream i got no zero notification by the way i had zero
notification about powworld's pod and then um so i was
confused i was like what happened to powworld and then uh
and then like i messaged my youtube guy about it but like he
didn't reply back in time and then the stream just came back
with the chat fixed i was like okay i said a lot of stuff.
I was gonna say, what did I say?
And I'm like, no, I said a lot of very sketchy things.
I'm just wondering, I'm just wondering if it had to do with
like, the YouTube like, bots being like, oh my she said so
much stuff.
And they're like, they're like concerned because the chat
was like, is this a hostage situation?
Because what the fuck is going on in chat too?
And that's why they took down the chat because like we both,
me and the dragoons, like both of us, it's not just me think
this was a team effort both of us said some very extreme
things during that stream so like i would not be surprised
if like the vod got flagged um by like the youtube bot
system and like so they took down the chat because they're
like they have to analyze the chat to see like what's going
on um because they're like maybe this isn't friendly for
viewers and then they're like all right We got to take down
this bot and match it up with the stream and see, see like
what's going on.
I'm not spreading the blame.
I'm sharing the blame.
Sharing is caring.
That's what Care Bears taught me.
Okay guys.
Did you not learn from Care Bears?
We gotta share it.
We got it.
Hey, chat was taken down.
It wasn't the bot that was taking down first.
It was chat that was taking down first.
They targeted the chat first so something happened in chat
that made YouTube be like we're gonna take the chat down
They didn't take the bot down first and then later they took
the bot down Oh, you want me oh yeah, you watch care bears
name all the care bears there's there's brave bear Wait, you
know, he's not brave.
No, that he's not bear.
He's he's a lion was brave brave heart.
No, he's a cousin.
Okay, okay, okay want to know, okay, there's Grumpy Bear,
there's Joy Bear, there's Braveheart, who's a cousin of the
Care Bears, there's Cheer Bear, there's Sunshine Bear,
there's Sleepy Bear, there's uh see i told you i know the
care bears and their cousins i used to watch care bears when
they did reruns like three two one go something something
care bears there okay maybe i don't remember care bear as
much as i thought maybe i had a care bear sona because i
really i actually drew a care bear sona back then because
they released the new care bear designs and i thought it was
super cute so i made myself a care bear Sona.
Um, because I thought it was real.
Who's Dumpy Bear?
Is there actually Dumpy Bear?
Please.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna look up Dumpy Bear because of you guys.
There's Bumpy Bear, Dumpy Bear.
Okay.
Uh, oh my god.
Okay, there was, there's no actual Dumpy Bear.
Care Bears.
Care Bear, Care Bear names.
Okay.
All right.
There's, oh my god, guys.
What's your care Bear What the fuck is going to be called
magical bear?
That's so stupid.
All right.
I know my care bears.
I don't know.
You guys know your...
I bet you guys...
Some of you guys aren't even old...
We're even old enough to watch the care bear TV show.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Speaking of that...
Speaking of like people not being old enough...
I actually...
Oh, there's friend bear.
There's friend bear.
There's tender heart bear.
There's share.
Oh my god.
I love wish bear.
Okay, wish bear was really cute.
I really liked wish bear's colors There's fun.
Why the fuck do we need fun shine bear and cheer bear?
It's redundant.
Your job is like redundant Your job is like you share the
same job.
There's what's the difference between true heart bear and
fucking tender heart bear You're both hearts the secret
bear.
That's not sharing secret bear should not exist secret bear
is like it's like that's not that does not like what does
that help with the children?
Kids should not have secrets.
If a child has a secret, you have to know the secret because
it could be a bad secret.
Like that's teaching kids bad things.
Secret bear is a bad secret.
It's a bad bear.
Anyway, let's see what I was gonna say.
Sorry, I got distracted.
okay speaking of children okay i need to tell you guys a
story um see sandland street sandland viewers get exclusive
convention stories uh because you are willing to watch part
six of a jrpg so i will treat you guys you guys get the
exclusive con stories all right so during like abcon during
abcon i was doing my panel Doakami, people who are at
Doakami knows the story because I told those at Doakami.
But like, during APCON, I was like, huh, I was like, okay, I
started dropping like fuck and like saying shit fuck and all
that stuff.
So I started dropping swears.
And then I was like, oh shit, I shouldn't be saying swears
because there might be children here.
But then I was like, oh, it's Australia.
It's all right.
You kids, Australians teach your kids swears at an early
age.
So it should be fine.
but then the thing is we had the q a portion um we were at
the q a portion of the panel and then the second person in
the q a wait no that second the first person who asked me a
question was a child
so i was like i because like he started talking on the mic
and i was like Wait, how old are you?
Wait, are you a child?
I was like, are you a child?
How old are you?
Please be older than 13.
And then the child was like, I'm 11.
I was like, oh, no, I'm...
I'm 11.
I was like, no!
It's over!
Oh, no!
All day, I had to watch my streams!
And he was like, you know, you know, I could put whatever
age I want when I twinked this.
And I'm like, no, that's not, that's not a good thing.
Oh, like, there's a reason why Discord has tighter
regulation regarding age of children signing up for Discord.
I'm like, no.
And then, and then, for his parents, his mom was right next
to him.
And I was like, I'm sorry, child.
I swore a lot.
like yeah you were dropping like f-bombs while I was just
sitting here and I'm just like what the fuck I got called
out by a child
um I got called out by a child oh my god um I got called out
by a child oh my god anyway um I felt very embarrassed that
day because I was I was not ready You know, I said that as a
joke.
Be like, he, he, uh, I can swear.
Because I assumed that everybody in the audience were not
children.
But there was children at the panel.
And I was not.
I was not.
I was not ready to find out there were children at the
panel.
I did not realize that parents were putting me on the iPads.
Like I was a cocoa melon of VTubers.
That is the day I found out.
I was a cocoa melon of VTubers.
youtubers you live long enough to become the villain the
plot twist the despair oh my god also apparently i'm also
like really really good with with her pets too i'm i am the
cocoa melon of youtubers because i had people come up and
was like I put your VOD You are my dog's Oshi because every
time Because like my dog is like super hyperactive But the
moment I put your VOD On for my dog She like calms down And
I'm like That's so funny and cool But now that cements the
fact That I am the cocoa melon of YouTube It is
Oh my god Um Um Um, real pain.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you.
I'm the dog whisperer.
Hi, today's my birthday and I was wondering if I could get a
happy birthday for my favorite bird with the most infectious
laughter.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And of course, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear pain.
And happy birthday to you.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Um.
But yes.
At least like, okay.
If I am being used as the, as your pets, as your pets like,
uh, a stream of choice, create a YouTube account for them
and subscribe to my channel.
That's, that's the least you can do, right?
yeah yeah but create a youtube account for your pet and
subscribe and gotta hit a million subscribers guys oh my god
i still can't believe children watch me i cry yeah i am oh
my god dokey bird for all ages guys dokey i'm so i'm
universally I'm universally age-appropriate, despite the
things I say.
Peachy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, no offense.
I don't think I trust you with my children.
What do you mean?
I'm the cocoa melon.
Okay, cocoa melon is not good for your kids, but okay, that
sounds right.
Because cocoa melon is, I talked about this before, but
cocoa melon is not good for your children, and it actually
stops brain development.
I'm not joking when I say that.
Cocoa melon actually, like, hurts your child's, like, brain
development because it's not, it doesn't grow the child's
brain.
Yeah, like, the CDC actually wrote out, yeah, because
they're like, you have to stop showing your children Cocoa
melon because your kids are not developing properly because
of that.
because of their channel um um yeah there's nothing
educational it's literally brain rot for children is but
that means i'm different i'm better i give you guys fun
facts guys i give you guys fun facts chat it's not i do not
rot your brain sometimes i give you guys really fun facts
hey thank you for the super chat thank you thank you what do
you mean you're not kid friendly so you're the reason my dog
also started to swear thank you for the secret chat thank
you thank you fun facts makes you smarter it does did you
guys know okay here's a fun fact so you guys know that the
mercy the pink mercy skin recently came back to overwatch
overwatch um and like i don't know if you guys know this but
there was an underground pink mercy what's it called black
market there was an underground pink mercy black market
before they like brought back the pink mercy skin so like
the skin the accounts who had pink mercy was because like
the charity thing was the only way to get it back then it
was like a one-time thing and like back then people were
selling accounts for like 400 to 500 dollars and that was
like the minimum budget people were like i only have a
budget for 500 please i really want a pink mercy skin and
like and like so there was like actually an underground
black market for pink mercy skin just just for that skin um
why is it pink because it was for breast cancer um and then
like i could i could have sold my count i don't know if you
guys noticed but selling a cancer is
yeah so so people so when the pink mercy skin came back like
last week the fucking thing crashed like the market crashed
so hard because obviously now you can now you can fucking
you know now you can buy it for like ten dollars just i
don't know i actually don't know how much it is because um
my main account is in hkd hong kong dollars so like i don't
know i i'm too lazy to put the version rate.
I didn't log into another account.
I didn't log into another account to see what the prices
was.
Um, also Blake, welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Um, but yeah, it's actually crazy that it's actually crazy
that just for the pink mercy skin itself, it was $400 to
$500 minimum.
I don't even know this because like, uh, because I saw like,
on twitter and somebody screencapped some poor mercy one
trick who's like please i only have a budget of 500 i really
want a pink mercy skin i can only go as high as 500 because
that is the budget i have like someone was willingly asking
for this for file i was like what the are you
couldn't i couldn't even believe that like people are
willingly paying that much for a fucking mercy skin of all
things like like it's not even the best skin like i'm sorry
mercy has like better skins than i'm sorry but i don't think
the pink mercy skin even looked that good like i owned it
from what the first from the very first charity like the
event that they did for like the og charity event and i'm
just like it doesn't even look that good it's just a fact
it's cute okay you can say it's cute though but like if you
look at the mercy tier skinless like the pink mercy is not
the best skin they have for mercy like i'm sorry like like
all it has is that it's pink i understand i understand
people are like i need everything to be pink but like it's
not even the best mercy skin of course there's a mercy skin
tier list you don't understand the mercy main main community
is I'm sorry for all the mercy play oh my gosh I'm so scared
I don't want the mercy community to like fucking flame me
but like you know what I already have like so many aunties
like I'll just get in the mercy aunties in here too like
like I'll just add mercy players as aunties as well it's
already too late um but i'm just the mercy community is so
scary as someone that um as someone that used to be in the
in like the overwatch community if you piss off the mercy
main community like it is like okay so you know like the
extreme side of like the really really bad side of like uh
of stands like doesn't matter what type of stands but like
but like before standing things was a thing they used like
they're they used to be like all within the mercy mean
community like it was basically like before stand stands
were a thing the mercy community was sort of like the og
type shit of um Like be extremely dedicated to mercy like if
you have one if you have a Negative opinion on mercy as a
character like you would get flamed so hard on Twitter Like
oh my god, I remember cuz like there was a whole movement
There was a whole movement where like mercy mercy mains were
asking for like Mercy to be buffed and then they're like was
it oh was it mercy rework or something it was like some
hashtag it was some fucking hashtag where it was like mercy
reworked or something I don't remember it was so long ago
and then and then like the other all the other players were
like uh were like I don't know guys like I think mercy is
good where it is and then if you had that opinion of being
like I think mercy is good where it is you would get flamed
so hard
because there was like and it got to the point oh yeah oh
yeah they like DDoS the official forums oh yeah yeah I
remember that it got so bad that like because there was a
huge movement regarding Mercy and then like rework Mercy
that they DDoS the official Blizzard forums because all they
did was like spamming the forums to demand a rework on Mercy
and then at one point I remember at one point they started
fighting amongst themselves because the leader of the
community got exposed to be the leader of the fucking rework
mercy movement got exposed to be like a hater or some shit
like she got like fucking revealed within like some fucking
twit longer or google doc to be like a really bad person so
then the mercy players were infighting amongst because
apparently the leader of the mercy movement would like shit
talk other mercy streamers um and then so they were like oh
my yeah it was a civil war within the mercy community
because the leader of the rework mercy movement was revealed
to be shit talking and like against other mercy streamers
and like being like a horrible person in general that she
ended up deleting her youtube channel because it was such a
bad expose that she deleted her youtube channel and Like,
privateed her Twitter account.
Because people were like, what the fuck?
Like, people were like, and then, and then they all, like,
if, and then there was no more leader.
And then the reworked Mercy Movement died.
Like,
yeah, the reworked Mercy Movement died because of it.
Because they canceled their own leader.
Oh, my God.
I was it was so bad but anyway yeah like i said like i'm i'm
i'm afraid of the mercy community sometimes too because um
they get very very passionate um about mercy in general i
mean people are willing to spend 500 dollars minimum on a
pink mercy skin and that shit is crazy i don't
Not no skin should be worth that much.
It was for charity, too.
It was for charity.
That's the worst part.
I feel like, Jesus Christ, you're selling a fucking skin
that was for breast cancer for $500 plus dollars.
Oh, my God.
I wonder if people can still, like, why do I know so much
about it?
Because it was, I used to frequent Overwatch TMZ.
much gossip regarding like the Overwatch community um and
and like um that was a whole arc that was there it was a
whole TMZ dedicated like a gossip a gossip like Reddit
regarding Overwatch community and it was so funny it was so
it was so interesting to read about because like I when I
used to be Play Overwatch I would read about me like alright
time to read my daily TMZ news regarding the Overwatch
community and like that that was like one of the arcs that
they had And alright, let's see rework mercy rework mercy.
Okay, let's see if I can Actually, I don't know if they
still if like if that's like is because I know like most of
the really the really popular like videos about reworking
mercy got uh deleted because um like i said it like the
leader got exposed to be a terrible oh there you go the
rework mercy movement i don't know this uh oh yeah if you
literally look up the hashtag uh rework mercy like you can
see like videos about it he's like join the rework mercy
movement today What about Ryan?
Like, I swear to God, everybody, like, they complain about
Mercy, but, like, Rhyme Players, Rhyme One Tricks, Rhyme
Means, had it the worst out of everybody.
Like, at least Mercy actually gets buffs.
Rhyme, Rhyme Players, has been fucked so hard for, like,
five plus years now, and they don't complain.
even know how they are still alive
oh my god Ryan Hart players are stronger than any of us Ryan
mains are actually like they're different they don't
complain they just they just exist and continue to throw and
greet games as Ryan they don't care if their character is
absolutely dog shit care they're just they'll keep hammering
and throwing other people's games by playing right it
doesn't matter to them they got problems but they keep going
rhyme mains are still different it hurts but we're used to
it I avoid every rhyme player I meet I'm sorry it doesn't
matter how good you are as right you're playing ryan like
what the fuck do you want me to do like yeah you might make
it work for like one game but one but it's like one game out
of 10 and like those i don't want to be the luckier side of
your good good gameplay of ryan i don't want to be the lucky
side of it no ryan reason to it yeah um But the big ham,
guys, it's Ryan Hart.
The only way that, like, the only way you guys can succeed
is if you make the other team also play Ryan.
But then if one of you, if the other team isn't a Ryan main
and they start losing, they'll pick Maga and fuck you up.
Like, what do you want?
Now, the rest of your team isn't into that.
You might be super into Ryan.
But the rest of the team wants to win.
I mean, he could stop saying the truth.
Anyway, we're finishing Sandland today.
Despite the long tangent we had, the 30-minute tangent we
had, guys, we're going to finish, I swear, we're going to
finish Sandland.
I need to reboot Sandland because it doesn't register my
controller.
But, like, despite the long, long tangent we had, the long
yab session, now, now we finish Sandland.
See, guys, if you come to Sandland streams, you get these
exclusive stories that the other dragons don't get.
These tad just only happens in Sandland.
You guys, yes, you guys got, like, you guys got spoiled
today.
We're going to beat the game, I swear to God.
Guys, we're going to beat the game.
Why can't I?
Why is my controller not registering?
Don't understand.
Oh, there we go.
Now it is.
All right, here we go.
We're actually going to beat the game for real, guys.
We're back in Sandland.
know this but we're back in sandland all right open the door
exclusive tangents yes that's right you guys get the
exclusive wait where am i supposed to go oh is it here
tricky jumper ken where which What's the objective?
Give the flowers.
Oh, here.
Okay.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God already went here.
Uh, but no, thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you.
Oh, this way?
Oh, yeah, it's this way.
All right.
See you guys.
I told you we're going to progress.
I told you guys.
General Ace.
Thank you for coming.
We have news for you.
you look even worse than the last time we saw you yeah what
happened you've been getting any sleep at all sleep hasn't
been part of my lexicon for the past few days what are you
doing i was in forest land what are you doing in the sunland
have another brutal meeting ahead so i can't talk long it
won't help with your sleep but here's our situation so far
quite confident in their strength epi says they've already
moved a huge force near the border our garrison along the
border won't stand a chance though to be frank that goes for
the entire don't we have an army too our entire thing was
being an army this entire country was run on by an army
we've prepared lodgings for you you can stay there for i
think it's also because i sort of destroyed half their army
too maybe that's the thing i'll be taking my leave now we'll
talk Yeah, you're right.
I was gonna say, wait, no, I destroyed half of their army.
I remember that.
But I also destroyed their army, too.
It's equivalent exchange.
If the Royal Army won't be able to stop the Forest Land Army
on its own, the resistance can't...
You don't want our help?
Wait, why not?
I just wanted to bring up the idea at the meeting first.
Who am I kidding?
This is no time to be worrying about proper procedure.
I'm sorry I rejected your offer of an alliance last time.
This time, allow me to be the one to make the proposal.
What's the proposal?
I want to join forces with you to take on the Forest Land
Army.
I thought that's what we're doing originally.
Now, we just need to get the king to take the threats
seriously.
Okay, but the king's worthless.
He's convinced that the capital at least is perfectly safe
and refuses to prepare for war.
What the fuck?
Is there anything we can do?
I appreciate the sentiment.
But this is my problem to solve.
I'll be back.
Why does the king not believe in us?
Will we ever defeat the bounty hunt?
Will we ever do my job?
Welcome.
And actually hunt some bounties.
Will you be staying the night?
Yeah, I will.
No.
The last final episode.
Yoki do her job in hunt bounties.
We look forward to your next visit.
Alright.
So, what's the plan?
Let's head to the royal palace.
Aure should be done with this meeting by now.
I wonder if they managed to change the king's mind.
I'll set him straight myself if he's still finding excuses.
Alright, kill me over here.
You're General Shiva.
It's an honor to meet you.
Yeah, that's me.
The tiny little guy here.
I don't go by.
Never mind.
I'd like to speak to Who's talking?
Is he coming out of my voice?
Yes, sir.
Where's actual General Shiva?
Your Majesty, please give me permission to fully mobilize
the army.
Do I have to?
Are you sure you really need to go that far?
Supreme Commander Zayu was able to keep them at bay all this
time with just the border patrol.
the situation has changed now yeah but that's because he was
working in line with him but still if the royal capital
falls don't you know your head will be the first to roll oh
general shiva what are you doing that's right i'm backing up
general are yeah i'm here too yeah that's me I exist don't
tell me have you joined forces with the demons to steal
control of the country this is why we abolish monarchy
because like we have people like him in power just cuz he's
like the son of somebody the forestland army the
princess of forestland and princess of that i now fight as a
member of the resistance aiming to strip i wonder how much
and i'm supposed to talk about the inbreeding part
maybe look at our oh my gosh i should say that maybe i might
i might get like i should talk about the inbreeding part
current monarchy systems She's the enemy of our enemy.
And you know what they say about them.
So you're telling me this enemy of our enemy and the traitor
general Shiva and the demons who overthrew my army's
commander are all on our side?
Yeah!
I just don't know anymore.
You're not supposed to think, King.
You're literally a puppet for the army.
Sayu is gone.
You're not his puppet anymore.
You're our puppet.
Please stand up for your country and become a chokey
uninvited from London I met in game guys abolish the
monarchy in game Just imagine what tragedies will befall the
people of this nation Everything I say is in game and
doesn't apply to real life Disclaimer Royal blood won't
protect you either You can end up on the gallows Okay, it's
a Sandlin bot They don't watch Sandlin We're safe.
We're hiding behind the Sandland Vodge.
It's true.
It's both your duty and in your interest to prevent that.
And the ladies just love a man who fight the fight.
What the fuck?
Does he not have a queen?
There's a reason why you can't find a queen in Sandland.
Do you think Forestland is going to be any different?
All right, General R.A.
I've graciously decided to leave everything up to you.
I'll do all I can.
Uh, reporting in.
The Forest Land Army has crossed the border and is deploying
into the southern desert as we speak.
Oh.
Oh my God, it's coming.
The Forest Land.
The Forest Landers.
Godspeed.
Them and they're like five tanks.
This will be all out war.
Are you ready?
I mean, I was already killing people already in game.
So, like, it's not going to be any different.
Let's do this.
Yay!
Oh my god.
5,000.
Okay.
Nope.
There has to be a faster way to get there.
I am not traveling 5,000.
Oh my gosh.
Thank God for fast travel, guys.
Thank fucking God.
You already spotted them?
All right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, it's so nice seeing you at the Doki Me panel.
I was so surprised when I saw you in the artist alley.
I took the picture for the artist way.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
I usually, I visit the artist alley before or before or
after.
There's so many.
Are these all?
Wait, are these all the army?
Oh, this has to be the army.
It's always fun to meet artists at the alley as well.
Because I love buying Toki merch.
What's funny is that they always be like, you can also have
anything else on the table.
And I was like, no, that's okay.
I just want myself.
I just...
And they're like, you know, you can also request anything
else here.
I was like, no, that's fine.
I just... I just really want me.
Like, that's really it.
Oh my god.
How strong are they?
Oh, shit.
Okay, these guys are super...
Okay, we're gonna...
We're gonna grab...
Nope, where's the...
How do I grab?
Okay, Rad, I need you to...
What do you mean, can't help?
Okay, we're gonna have to get rid of the officer.
This is the officer.
Oh my god, Nikki, thank you for the Akasupa!
You did it, you created...
You created an account for your die!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you.
See guys, I'm on your dogs.
Oh, she Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, who gave this dog a credit
card?
Yo, but also who the fuck gave this dog a credit card?
He did it Nikki
I'm popular for that with the dogs Guys, you're yourself an
Oshi who has dogs as fans.
Also cats, do cats like me too?
Guys, I need to know, do cats like me as well?
Okay, let's grab the bike.
Our very under level bike.
I trust Niki with my finances.
Alright.
Is this the right one?
No, we have to find the one that has No name tag.
This one.
This is the officer.
No wonder he hits so hard.
Whoa!
Thanks for taking it!
Oh, that's awkward.
That is so awkward.
All right.
Don't worry.
We'll tell your wife.
We'll tell your wife while I'm in bed with her that you died
honorably.
Okay.
Let's get rid of him.
And then reload.
All right.
Man down.
Man, yeah, wait, what, what, huh?
All right, nice.
That should be everybody, right?
All right, there's still two more.
Oh, shit, he died?
What happened?
Who's dying?
Sandland Army's getting its butt kicked.
What do you mean?
I'm doing everywhere.
I'm doing everywhere, everything I can.
Let's take out their army's brain.
That's fine.
That's why I've been doing this entire time.
This is so easy.
Okay.
It's fine.
They're almost dead.
He's holding still for me.
Oh nice.
It's okay.
They're level 18?
Okay.
I think my tank's also level 18 though to be fair.
Now they don't know what to do.
Their brain's dead.
all right nice then we got roilo oh my god what kind of army
is this when is dad gonna get a youtube channel so nikki the
doggo can finally watch her stream thank you for the super
chat dark thank you thank you no no i'm sharing dad and i
are sharing a channel together we don't want to split the
subs us winning the battle won't win sandland the war yeah
imagine if i hadn't upgraded the tank yeah that would have
been really awkward oh thank god thank god upgraded the tank
guys that was my idea chat to upgrade the tank boom okay i
alerted the guards which one is the tank the brain nope is
this one it has to be this one right are you the brain yeah
you are oh Oh, I caught you!
I caught you!
I knew it.
I fucking see you.
You thought you could pretend to be just like the other
tanks?
You forest landers.
I'm not that stupid.
I might be from Sandland, but I'm not that stupid.
Alapaka, thank you for that!
Five gifted chips, thank you!
Okay, that's good that we have the others.
Oh, Link Cat, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
Glad I could be part of the crowd at one of your karaoke
appearances.
Funny that end up being all the way over in Germany of all
places.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Is that you?
You have the profile picture.
Wait, there's more?
How is there more?
Okay.
I can't It's like a whole entire army.
Who would have thought?
Wait, can I just go here?
Would I fail my mission if I...
No, I didn't.
Okay, thank God.
That would have been awkward.
We can't take much more of this.
We should consider retreating.
Did I miss up?
Joining forces.
nearly every tank in the royal army
oh my god did i left this war without our tanks but not
without you oh okay okay that's good that's fine i was like
i was so worried i was like oh my gosh did i fuck up the
more did i fuck up the mission because i left because i fast
traveled oh shit that's a big tank aren't big tank oh
there's too many of them there's so many wives to go to bed
with to tell them that their husband died honorably general
all right get it i did there shouldn't be any other unless
don't tell me tell you what
oh my god he fits in the tank
He brought like four tanks.
Like, I don't know if that's going to help.
He's leading Seiyu's elite guard into battle.
That's the king.
To think he would make a personal appearance on the front
lines.
You call that fit.
He's stuck.
But don't kill them.
Take the king alive.
Oh my god.
All I'm saying is that, like, what the fuck?
Fuck, it's like, holy shit, you just got run over the other
tank.
Our best strategy is to get in close.
Okay, I'm as close as I can be.
I don't know.
Oh shit, oh shit.
It's like fucking lagged my tank at one point.
Oh my god, my tank started lagging when he started firing.
It's just too big.
Prince, will you be okay?
Oh, I don't know.
This is a big tank.
Oh, no.
Guys, I don't know, guys.
I don't know anymore.
I have to get every shot.
Holy shit.
Bro, please.
I need help.
I need assistance.
Wait, what?
Did it work?
Did I do it?
Don't think this is over just yet.
She was like half HP.
And then she gave up What a coward you running away after
half HP couldn't be me
There's still be so many of them left
There's a phase to just like like just like souls Your
majesty please retreat you've done enough I How did he get
when he was stuck?
How did he get in?
Like...
The rest is up to you, General R.A.
Okay, bye.
Someone oil him up!
We gotta oil him up so he can slip out.
Get the plunger.
Get the king plunger.
Oh my god.
All three of them.
threatening get the butter oh is he okay all right do you
have a wife we're pulling out sandland there's not even
blood how is he badly wounded Destruction is a better part
of Valor.
Just focus on staying alive.
But tell me you hurt.
If I withdraw, who will command the army?
This old soldier, if you'll let me.
Bro, I don't know.
Like, he's just a stick.
You have to ask.
You wiped the floor with me.
Like I didn't know which hand of the gun to hold.
If you'll be the one taking charge, I'll gladly step back
and leave it to you.
Oh my god!
That was my puppet!
I'm going to control an army!
Yeah, isn't there like a chain of command?
Doesn't he have a second in command?
I feel bad for his second in command, and he's just like,
this is it, this is my time to find this show, the military,
what I'm made of.
prove myself to General Ari and then he's like to this old
man that's retired 50 years ago you can be the new commander
this is a strategic withdrawal our priority is to minimize
casualties true I mean he is the legend and then some old
guy just shoves you inside like he's like that what was it
like Conan O'Brien and that other guy
Everyone, stop here.
Are you sure, General?
We're highly visible here.
It's all right.
Jay Leno, yeah, he's like, Jay Leno, step aside.
I'm coming back.
You should be able to hit them from that position.
That's right.
Our eyes are trained in Sandland.
you idiots change location yeah that's right forest landers
you didn't have the sun because you had your trees covering
it all up
he got spoiled by your trees what happened did you copy or
you hit they got the cannon space and suspension it's out of
action weak forest lander i'm
don't worry we're overwhelming them with sheer force what
two that's two we have three
also i would yeah i was gonna say why did not give the
soldiers sunglasses
holy shit when did my tank go so fast
it's david versus kalaif Rosetta and Is this your idea of
justice?
As if an ally of demons has the right.
Yeah You've got it wrong.
They're not the monsters you think they are at all.
Shush your half demons of a half demon.
Yeah, oh my gosh Oh shit.
I said that's a joke.
Oh my gosh.
She's pretty racist
Keep your naive ideals in your.
Whoa Battlefield This, darn this oversized tank.
Actual racism.
Oh, my God.
And I wanted.
Is that it?
Am I just gonna run away?
Fighter!
What's our condition?
When did he fucking die?
No way.
Yeah, I was like, what?
Why did he get into a coma?
What do you mean?
He won't wake up.
He just had a chest wound.
How did that affect the brain?
Like,
how did that travel all the way to the mind?
I don't want beer o'clock Okay, where am I supposed to go
guys a beer o'clock?
Okay, I go back Just a chest roof.
What now?
Are you gonna go see R.A.
right away?
No.
We should really take a short break too.
Let's stay the night at that inn here ranged first.
Should we go back and help R.
No, let's just sleep.
It's alright.
He's still in a coma.
It doesn't matter.
He'll wake up eventually.
Stay.
Please make yourselves at home.
It's alright.
He's in a coma.
He'll wake up, right?
all right i'm gonna eat my lunch while we're waiting for him
to wake up from his coma i hope you're well rested we look
forward to your next yeah all right i gotta head over guys
he's gonna wake up right right he's gonna wake up guys i
didn't realize he went into a goddamn coma but he's gonna
wake up all right let us in General Siva.
What brings you here today?
You know why I'm here.
I can't even see Ari and plan our next moves.
May I see him?
Say no more.
You'll find the general in the command center.
Wait, is he awake?
General Ari?
Wait, you're back up?
I thought you were in a coma!
Thanks to that little nap.
I'm well rested.
You're feeling great.
You were freaking shot.
He was just eeppy.
Fighting on through sheer willpower will come back to bite
you later.
Look, it's nothing that I can't handle, alright?
Ah, to be young.
All joking aside, though.
What's the forest land army up to?
According to the latest reports from the forest, field.
We have been able to confirm that they've established three
bases within Sandland.
What the fuck?
It's been a day.
How did they build three bases?
That's so fast.
They have occupied several Sandland army bases.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
But like they built three in a day?
That doesn't sound good.
What's the plan?
we'll have to shut them down one by one we're preparing to
sort it as we speak you have our support once they establish
a supply chain and line of communication they brought their
goddamn trees to build those spaces I'm sick and tired of
being on a losing streak let's kick what what do you mean
losing streak we fucking killed so many people
Okay, what do we need?
New parts can be made at the base.
We need to join forces.
We need to...
Okay, these are all the bases.
I'm gonna see if I can upgrade.
I'm gonna check if we can upgrade anything.
Kick out the force land squatters.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, no name.
Alright.
We're gonna...
We're gonna see if we can upgrade our tank.
Hmm.
Do you need any?
Mm-hmm.
Let's see.
Dragoons.
What do we need for premium steel and premium bulk?
I'm pretty sure I could make those, right?
Let's go all in on the tank at this point.
I feel like I feel like we can just go all in on getting
better tanks.
All right, let's see.
Okay, we don't have new parts, but I think we can upgrade
our parts, right?
Premium seal, premium meter, premium gunpowder.
All right.
See you later.
We gotta go to the parts lady.
Parts lady.
Oh my god, Master Drop.
Thank you for the 50 gift and chips.
Thank you.
Really appreciate it.
All right, where's the premium shit?
Do you not have premium stuff?
fuck give me back my give me back my bro bob was better the
forest landers had premium stuff hey is it oh oh nice i got
oh oh wait isn't this really good wait which one was good
i'm where you guys told me to um get some of their gun stuff
Which one was good?
Purple guns?
Yeah, but which one?
Can we get the EMP gun and laser?
Okay, we're gonna grab that.
And then we're gonna grab that.
Alright.
Bring me any rare items you find.
Alright, let's see.
Let's see how good the parts are, though.
I heard, like, you guys were saying that the guns and lasers
were really good from the cat guy.
From Najin Boo.
Parts.
Uh, customized vehicle.
Uh.
I don't know.
I got EMP gun.
Wait, but then the damage isn't as good though.
But the damage is so low.
Is it worth it?
Or now?
Um, lower damage, but...
Uh.
Is it worth it though?
guys or should i keep maybe upgrade damages and everything
damages everything
i don't know what you're talking about damages everything
okay we'll try it what world do you live in where you think
damages and everything also what else did i buy i don't
remember what else What else did I buy?
Other than this.
I don't remember.
For what...
Where did the laser go?
Wait, which tank uses the laser?
Because clearly it's not any of this.
Big number makes Ungabunga Brain happy.
Oh, it's in...
Which one is the...
Which one was the laser?
Oh, the laser was the mecha?
was this no it wasn't we didn't which one was a laser where
the fuck where did i buy the laser for
uh the hover one was it the hover what the fuck i don't
remember which gun was for the laser let's check under
options later okay options okay wait what options wait i'm
confused i'm confused it's an option part oh okay that's an
option part what's that mean oh here oh virus of power was
causing you destructive you know what fuck it let's go
damage all in uh and then we upgrade part apparently okay we
need where the are getting premium meter and premium steel
we do not have either of those i guess we have to i'm gonna
go visit i guess i have to visit like the other side you're
right who needs armor when you have laser we need like
premium steel um we need to go to here?
These guys might have it.
The junker market might have it.
Does he sell it?
Armor up.
No, he doesn't sell it.
Do you sell it?
Do you make the good shit?
You do!
Okay, that's good.
Okay, we're gonna grab all of the premium... What is it?
Premium steel and premium bolt, right?
Okay, we need A lot of premium steel.
And then we need a premium bolt, right?
How many premium bolts did we need?
I don't remember.
Oh my god, this guy...
Why can't I have him in my town?
Why...
Why can't he live with us?
We have four premium bolts just in case.
Thank you for coming.
need we don't need what what's her name workshop lady this
is better workshop lady kidnapping all right let's see i
actually don't remember what we needed so i'm gonna double
check two plus two is five right i don't know i don't
remember all right because i want to upgrade my laser all
right parts upgrade part okay we need premium meter okay we
have justin premium meter oh shit okay see you later there's
premium meter all right we got we all hope that they're not
gonna be using my premium steel to make the premium meter
because that would be very uh very awkward get the a n drive
what the fuck is your what the fuck is an en drive uh oh
nope we gotta go here and then talk to premium meter oh god
i hope wait how many i forgot how many do i need to get for
the premium meter premium meter guys it goes in one ear and
out the other guys it doesn't matter they don't have premium
meter what the fuck is a premium meter how do you not have
premium meter?
I don't know what it is, but how do you not have premium
meter?
Where do I get premium meter?
The forest land workshop would have premium meter.
They drop from enemies?
What kind of enemies?
Maybe.
What kind of enemies drop meters?
What the fuck?
What even is a meter?
Okay, no, it's a meter, but premium.
Bob would have had a premium.
Do you have a premium meter?
What kind of enemies drop premium meter?
One meter equal.
A unit of measurement.
Okay, this is not...
Okay, this is not the right gun.
Boom.
Oh, that is overkill.
Nice.
Oh, I got premium gear.
All right, are these all the bad guys here?
Oh, that's it?
No, I just went the wrong way.
Never mind.
They weren't even part of the enemies.
Okay, sorry.
I went the wrong way.
Thank you, Zion, for the...
for the backseating.
I really appreciate it.
Queenie, what is it?
God, you were a Canadian.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's splashing.
Boom.
Okay.
Apparently there is the forest land officer here somewhere.
Is it this guy?
Oh, it is this guy.
it's okay the laser is coming in oh my god he can block too
that should be illegal
oh god don't worry don't worry he can't block all of this oh
wait that damage is insane wait a minute that's some insane
damage right there holy shit all right then we you get like
wait that is insane all right do i get premium meter premium
gear premium premium meter we did it we got premium meter
price drop by have ramley assigned so to get the best part
be as many enemies as you can legendary rare or even higher
capacity oh wait that's like legendary part all right you
guys don't matter apparently so i can just shoot you guys
away and then steal your part here make sure to check your
gear every now and then all right nice we finally got we got
another premium meter come in handy nice all right that
counter offensive such a waste to let bot parts just rust
away too enough beat everybody i'll give them a look you
know what i'm gonna defeat these guys for the premium meters
we we actually need upgrades like It might be, it actually
might be a good idea to kill these guys for, like, some
upgrades now.
Alright, so everybody, did I do it?
It's just counter-offensive.
What does that mean?
Finally, I finally learned what a meter was!
Looks like we're not the only travelers out here.
Is that it?
We should think about stopping by that campsite they're
using ourselves.
communal camp that's open to all travelers use LBRT LBRT oh
I see it I think I'm pretty sure I killed everybody right no
because it keeps telling me to go back what who's still
alive who's still alive
alive and do you have a way for me to tell that you are a
hero you should check the map oh there they are oh okay yeah
i did not realize okay you know what i'm gonna oh wait oh
he's already dead
look all i'm saying is that i will make sure i will make
sure that your family knows you were a
oil.
We're doing all that scorpion oil over there.
Can I rob you guys?
Is there stuff to steal?
Nope.
Okay.
Alright.
It's time to go back to Spino.
The wife hunter.
There's a bounty on your what?
Oh wow.
I can't believe there's a bounty on you sir.
Do you need any?
Alright.
Let's see.
uh upgrade part oh my god finally okay premium gun powder
okay i think i can also customize vehicle upgrade dragons
right uh vehicle upgrade vehicle uh i need premium steel i
need one more premium steel oh i don't have premium ore i
don't know where to find premium ore there's so many
all I'm saying what do you mean it's bad I'll have you know
I'm the cocoa melon of YouTube
all right let's see uh do I have no checkpoint around here
holy shit I actually don't I never went to the hidden it's
hidden how was I supposed to know where the hidden Cliff
Village was.
Not the Coco Melonavitubers.
You're not supposed to say that's a positive thing.
Okay.
What's this?
Get the flowers?
No.
I don't care about this child's flowers.
I gotta figure out how to get here.
You could look for it.
I don't know what type of ores that is.
There's so many ores around me They could be bad ores.
Oh, is this the way the flowers are?
You ran into a tough enemy Doki melon the brain your eyes
Yeah, they give us It's a demon Is that you knocker?
Oh, Prince?
What are you doing here?
I should be asking you.
Yeah, why is a demon picking flowers?
She's blind for a blind girl for a child a secret oh knocker
oh knocker are you scheming something so bad you can't talk
about it not at all actually it's the opposite wait you're
the one bringing flowers to that blind girl oh so you're the
goody two shoes okay but why is he bringing flowers to a
blind child this is exactly why i didn't want you to know
well this is certainly a twist but why do that for a human
yeah she complimented my singing what the fuck how old are
first off knocker how old are you like i was walking along
humming to myself when suddenly i heard clapping When I
looked around, there she was.
She said I was good.
Are you that good a singer?
I like to sing, but no, I'm not very good.
But she still thanked me.
She said interesting scents and sounds make her happy.
So you've been bringing her flowers.
I wanted her to enjoy their scent.
That's pretty sweet.
Why don't you just sing for her if she's sure that we're
good?
I can't.
She won't be happy anymore.
She's literally blind.
She doesn't know the concept of demons.
I'm not so sure about that.
She doesn't even know what they look like.
Because she's blind.
She was looking for you so she could thank you.
I don't need her to.
Once was enough.
Never mind that.
Prince, I have a request.
What?
What is it?
The thing is, I want some Alpha Raptor essence.
What the fuck do you want?
You want to be an alpha?
What for?
I need it to make a cure for her sight.
But I'm not strong enough to defeat an alpha raptor.
You could cure her sight using that essence.
What?
Where did we get there?
First off, it was just bring flowers to a girl that would
compliment you.
And now you're like, I'm going to cure her blindness now.
Yeah.
All right.
We'll see to it.
yeah is that okay with you prince guys this is why you need
compliment people more like what's up this guy is deprived
of compliments he's he gets one compliment and now he's
gonna fix the blind you mean it great if you what if the
next person you compliment here is cancer because of you
there's an alpharaster west of here you just have to beat it
west got it get the other ingredients in the meantime.
What?
I think I already killed one already.
Wait, where did he go?
Pretty sure I have.
I've killed so many dinos.
I haven't?
Wait, I actually haven't killed a raptor?
Oh my god.
I am like...
I think, like, I'm losing my touch.
You mean I didn't kill a raptor?
But I killed so many!
Guys, I know you're trying to compliment me, guys, but I'm
not going to be the person that's going to cure cancer.
I'm sorry.
Oh, shit, I forgot.
This is the jump bot.
God damn it.
All right, let's see.
God damn, I forgot.
Sorry, that was the shoot button.
I was so used to shooting.
I don't remember any other buttons.
the premium ore maybe the premium ore is over there but you
might okay guys guys i need you guys to stop coping here i'm
a fucking vtuber not a doctor or a scientist any outsiders
going to the capital are required to pass through a military
checkpoint what does that mean how do we get there turn back
anyone suspicious i gather how do we how do we get there
dick went the wrong way how do we get there oh i guess i'm
just gonna fuck it i'm i jumped all the way here for no
reason i can't look at this map man why is this okay let's
see we gotta get up here and then we go this way all right
here we go this map is so difficult to look at where are the
ores I don't understand oh okay we got a wrong way oh that
was a cool Akira Akira thing but like I need to get this all
right nice all right off we go all right Time to kill more
forest that's all right.
I meant forest landers guys not sand landers forest land I
fight for you guys.
I fight for the people Or like for whichever army pays me
more.
I'm a mercenary It's all about the money I got the I would
love to get to discover something that no one's ever seen
before all right time to swap gotta make the most of the
journey no more than rest which where's the boss there you
go where's big boss that's right i got a laser now and it's
fully oh my god wait okay i sort of wasted that charge oops
the charges and stuff because i don't know how much charges
how long i've charged to forget the full power come on i
know you're here why are you hiding behind a rock okay nice
oh my god he used his men to block my charge okay last one
all right now for the people i don't know what this bike is
gonna do but okay are you just gonna ram into me okay that's
it no more mr nice guy all right that's one of them down oh
my gosh you guys are very brave don't worry you guys are
very brave i'll admit i'm gonna steal your loot we should
keep our distance from the army base and less nest i think
we took out all the enemies here oh there's so much loot all
right let's head to the next base is there any loot.
I love loot.
Is there more stuff?
Did you guys left at this base?
You built this in one day?
Jesus Christ, how did I build this in one day?
There's loot over there!
Yeah, there's so much, so many purples.
Alright, going... Wait, why is there, like, empty scrap
here?
Who died there?
Who fucking died there?
Hey, you see that raptor?
a tough enemy sorry you see that raptor well i'd start by
observing them carefully knowing what they can do and what
their weaknesses are will help you fight your mom's dead yay
but he's gonna look pretty she's gonna look pretty on my
team dookino but she'll look beautiful hung up on my wall
let's see you know what no i don't need i don't need to kill
the scorpions because like uh because like uh all we need is
premium shit now you don't need like stuff from the from the
animals yeah oh my god look such a happy family
but we can kill this guy oh it's the alpha raptor we need to
kill him anyway for the essence it's for the essence guys
you don't understand oh okay all right no wonder he's the
alpha all right there you go nice let's take it to knocker
and then you're a child right yeah that's a child i gotta
make sure i shoot the right one give me a sec there we go
all right live on childhood you're free now Child, you're
free to do whatever you want.
You have the whole land to yourself.
I'm the alpha now.
All right, let's see.
We got, is he still chasing me?
Look, he's having a great time.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that was a little overkill for these guys.
At least that was sort of fun.
Oh, all right.
You called me a monster, but Beezobub was like, Hey, that
was fun, I guess.
What does that say about Beezobub?
It's like, that was fun.
Okay, I gotta get rid of these guys.
Okay.
Get over here.
Get out of here.
Get this hover fucking craft out of here.
Get this hovercraft out of here.
Oh, shit!
Get...
Whoa!
No!
Okay, we need a repair.
Yeah, he's a demon that doesn't kill with exceptions.
He's like, but I don't kill.
But then clearly, clearly he has exceptions.
It's a lie.
He does kill.
Yeah.
Let me get rid of.
him and then i'm gonna get rid of him oh ow all right
where's this guy there you go there you go nice he only
kills when it's fun and i'm the monster here oh there's the
boss there's a there's the boss okay i'm gonna charge this
up we thought it didn't hit him all right we got whoa okay
we gotta make sure he doesn't punch us there you go oh look
at that damage though you're both monsters there's no like
distinguish that's not true i'm only doing what the game's
telling me to do at best i'm a puppet i'm just a puppet
I'm just learning from my artificial intelligence.
Yeah.
At least that was sort of fun.
Did it?
We've now destroyed every place.
Just following orders, exactly.
Let's go back to the command center to find the other bases.
There's more?
Oh yeah, the Sandline bases.
Yeah, I almost forgot about that.
Because we killed the bases that are...
The bases that are like, uh, what is it called?
That they built themselves.
So now we have to kill the ones that, uh, took over in
Sandland.
Alright.
Yeah, good soldiers follow orders.
And I'm a good soldier.
Do you need it?
Uh, let's see.
Upgrade part.
Oh, yeah.
Customized vehicle.
I got so many parts.
Ooh.
Shots explode on impact with a chance on enemies.
Should I just keep the EMP gun or do it the purpose?
I don't know.
Fires in.
Oh my god, that guy, that's too late.
Do I just, do I just like stay?
Keep the EMP?
Okay.
I'll keep the EMP then.
Oh my god, but there's so many like, uh, let's see.
Explosive lasers.
Oh, good luck charm.
Chip that works.
So I increase the chance of defeating it dropping.
good luck charm i'll take the good luck how much do i need
to okay customize vehicle uh upgrade part i need premium
steel still god damn it i don't have enough i don't have
enough like you can make a backup tank i don't need backup i
don't need backup
They're still... Oh, wait, I can upgrade this.
Okay, we'll upgrade that then.
Uh, super hard crockdoor alloy.
What the fuck?
Do I have one of those?
Like, I don't know.
Oh, I can get another chip slot!
Yes!
Finally!
Alright, and then...
Parts...
Uh, customized.
Finally, I can have another chip slot.
Power chip.
Oh, machine gun.
Quick reload.
Incinerary.
Chip.
When using cannons.
Oh, I like that.
I want them to be on fire.
Acceleration combat.
Increases vehicles.
Reduces cannon reload time.
Quick reload would be nice.
But I feel like my laser does that affect the charge itself?
I think that's fine.
I think the incinerary is better.
Uh.
Would it actually be better?
I don't know.
I'm using the other...
I use the other gun until my reload's done.
I mean, I could try quick reload.
I'll try quick reload.
Okay.
See you later.
Yeah, I feel like the gun reloads pretty fast.
That's why I'm going to do incinerary.
I'm going to do incinerary just because I feel like...
I feel like I reload really fast already.
So, like, I don't think I need it.
I rather have the incinerary.
See you later.
Alright.
We go.
Go now.
I just need to find more premium ore.
Wherever that is.
God damn, you should...
I need to find more ore in Forestland.
That's where they have all the good shit.
Forestland has all the good shit.
All right, here we go.
I'm heading to the capital.
Why do you always ask me that?
Just let me in.
I'd like to speak to General Arey.
I literally outrank you.
All right, time to eat more of my lunch.
Ah, just in time.
I was just thinking of contacting you.
Yeah, that's me.
We've identified the location of the remaining force land
army bases.
It'll be a breeze All right, let's go crush the rest of them
Munch munch wait what okay never mind I guess not I thought
I thought this was gonna be a logger cutscene What the fuck
it there.
I am ready Never mind Off we go Okay Alright.
I thought it'd be a longer cutscene, but that's okay.
Here I'll go.
Okay, it's this way.
Where the fucking...
What are they called?
What are these guys called again?
The rebel gangsters doing here?
Not caring about how there's a war right now with the forest
land is?
Alright, there's one of those bases.
no time to eat soldier it's time for war all right is that
it i can barely see because there's a giant checkpoint in
front of me all right okay whoa whoa all right get away from
me nice all right we gotta make sure we shoot Shoot the
tank.
It's a tank.
Okay, we got reload.
And then shoot the humans.
And then...
See, we don't need the reload.
The reload is already so strong.
Oh my god, did I get him?
Okay, I did.
I couldn't tell.
It's so hard to tell sometimes.
This giant checkpoint is actually so...
No, I...
The giant fucking area of you.
Like, this is where you have to go.
all right nice we got one checkpoint back oh you're still
alive your friends are dead all right now everybody's dead
we took out all the enemies here yeah pretty sure all right
let's head to the next base i'm gonna rob your wallet too uh
next base is over here how do we get here i need to figure
out how to get here how the fuck do i get there.
Is that any water?
That's in the water, right?
I feel like that's in the water.
There's like a bridge here.
What the fuck do I...
What?
I hope it's in the water.
Alright, let's see.
The worst part is that this car is so slow and i can't you
can't go faster it's such a slow car oh my god it looks like
we're not the only travelers out here we should think about
stopping by that campsite they're using ourselves which
campsite there's a campsite here that's open to all
travelers really about convenient it's open to all travelers
it feels like it's being it's open to the rebels right now
or the sand land it that's forced that sorry they're all
blurring together i've been like on so many different sides
i've been visible didn't kill anyone to say oh you're right
you're so you're so true man so true persona they give us a
super chat thank you thank you it's not my fault my tank
hits somebody what do you call that in the legal system you
know like hit it it's not like are a thing and then all
right how do i get up there by observing them carefully
knowing what they can do and just get off this will help you
fight effectively not a good try that next time what the how
do i get up there yeah it's not like manslaughter is a real
fucking crime or anything.
Alright.
Do I get up from here?
Oh, it's from here.
Okay.
Nice.
We figured it out.
You're honored to knife kill them, not me.
Wait, we figured it out, guys.
Are these the bad guys?
Oh, shit!
Hey there!
Hey guys, guys, I found the bad guys.
I found the bad guys.
It's okay.
I did it.
I found him.
They were guys who would have thought they were the bad
guys.
Oh my god.
I cannot see.
I can't see.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
That was like so many different things on my screen.
all right nice give me your shit give me your money what's
over here what were they hiding from down here they're
hiding anything oh it's like a little checkpoint oh it's a
secret tunnel
who's that
goodbye this man was just
And he's gone now.
Not God, that's secret.
You should check the map.
This guy was just checking his phone and was like, oh my
god.
I have a new message.
Let's see.
Gotta go here.
There's apparently more people over there.
Does my tank fit through?
It does.
Oh my god, guys.
I can't believe I just got promoted.
Oh, did you guys hear that?
She was like, did you hear that over there?
I wonder what could that be?
Oh, God, he's upstairs.
Oh, I cannot aim there.
Alright.
The longest run of your life.
Nice.
Alright.
I think we took out all the enemies here.
Must have been the win.
Alright.
Let's head to the next one.
next base.
All right, next base.
Where's the next base?
Where is it?
Oh, it's over here.
How the fuck do I get there?
How do I get there?
How the fuck do I get here?
Okay, this I assume is here.
Take that!
I need a figure.
How the fuck?
How the fuck do I get Is it from here?
Oh, it's on the other side of the water.
Oh, whoops.
Wrong side.
Wait, no.
Right side.
I could just get through from the water here.
Okay.
There's need to hover.
Hover time.
There's another area right there that I can hover.
Whoops, you said.
I can't tell the map is so difficult it's not a me issue
it's a map issue the map is so difficult to read the journey
no holding back all right up we go guys that bridge there
there was a gap in there you don't understand you didn't see
it but my gamer eyes I could tell there was like a huge gap
in between so there was no way to get across that bridge i
know you guys can't see it because you don't have the gamer
eyes like me but there all right let's see there it looks
like we're not the only travelers out here we should think
about stopping by that campsite they're using ourselves oh
wait that was not big boss that was just some rat that was
just a random right there.
Alright, that guy's dead.
Because I was like, there's no way that guy died so fast.
It's a communal camp that's open to all travelers.
Yeah, including me.
Alright, where's the...
Where's the main guy?
Is that the main guy?
Oh, that is.
Okay.
Wait, no.
Oh, that's the main guy.
Okay.
Woo!
yeah you think you're stronger than me i literally you know
what i'm gonna overkill i'm gonna do it i do it is he oh
shit what did i
see i told you guys there was no bridge I told you What do
you mean there was I told you you guys were like wow Doki
you're fucking coping Doki There's a bridge right here.
I told you there was a hole Nobody believed my hole
Hopefully it will serve as a reminder to never make the same
mistake again Like wow Doki why didn't you just like you
cross the bridge over there Nobody believed in me when I
said there was a hole I hate it.
All right.
Here we go.
You guys were like, Doki, you're fucking coping.
You just crossed the bridge.
What bridge?
I blew that bridge up.
The bridge, the spot.
You guys were like, well, Doki, crossed the bridge.
It was literally right next to you.
To be fair.
I actually made that shit up about They're not being a
bridge Because even I was like, wait Was there actually a
bridge?
And then I was right I was just a psychic I knew I
forewarned The missing bridge
Alright, let's see I was just psychic I could read the
future Let's see How do I use this laser I Like, how do I
use this?
I'm going to use it for this one guy.
That's how you...
Oh my god, I'm so stupid.
That's how you use it.
Guys, I figured it out.
I figured out how to use the laser.
Wait, that's so cool.
Why didn't I use that before?
All right, let's get rid of...
Let's get rid of the little guys first.
Because these guys are very annoying.
All right, where's the big guy?
Big guy, where are you?
There you are, big boy.
Oh, I missed.
But, like, there you are for real.
Oh, I should heal.
Give me a sec.
I should really heal.
All right, so we don't go through that issue again.
What the fuck are you doing?
I'm creating a desert?
Okay.
How did I miss again?
Oh.
Alright.
Oh, I was reloading.
I didn't even know I was reloading.
But I can't see so many things at once!
Okay.
Nice.
That was sort of fun.
Easy.
So easy.
I think so too, right?
All right, let's head to the next base.
How do we go to the next base?
Can we go through here?
I can!
Oh my god!
The kingly base!
Wait, I'm already here!
Where are they?
Wait, where are they?
Where's the bad guys?
Oh, there's the bad guys.
Don't worry.
Sorry.
Whoops.
Oh, it's okay.
He can't go upstairs.
And I can't shoot down, too.
Equivalent exchange.
Can I just roll down here?
My tank will be okay.
Yeah, my tank.
See, my tank's okay.
Wait, he blocked?
Wait, he can block.
That's illegal.
Fight.
me man what the is he doing wait he's literally just flying
what is he doing oh okay now you fucking fight back okay oh
use the laser you're right i'm gonna do it i know how to use
it now there we go oh my god that was instant That was
actually just instant.
Alright, let's reload.
And then...
Wait, we gotta reload this one too.
Wait, is there another officer?
No, he just doesn't have HP because he does not important
enough.
Just not important enough, man.
What can I say?
That fuck?
Are you still alive?
Yeah, that's actually really good against bosses, I think.
head back to the command center i did it i saved the world
the world being only sandland but that's all that matters we
rarely let loose with this we should be able to delay their
invasion well as long as that giant tank unit doesn't
remobilize that is rosetta didn't show up at any of these
battles did she go to forest land are we going back to
forest land maybe i just got used to it as unique as hers
probably can't be repaired out in the field thankfully
that'll buy us some time hey nice one prince
wait that's not mine wait who is it who's calling me your
phone who's this mine
We should call me Sir Croa, but anyway, it's Dr. Croa.
It's like those people are like, um, it's Doctor.
Wouldn't it be better to tell me now?
Never know who might be listening.
Can't say this on air.
Just hurry.
Believe me, it'll blow you away.
It's gonna blow me away.
Come on.
He wouldn't ask this of us without cause.
Let's go.
I'll inform General R.A.
by radio.
Alright, I didn't get knighted just to be not called, sir.
Alright, let's see.
Where is he?
Where does he live?
Where the fuck?
What?
Is he in forest?
Oh, we have to go to forest land.
Alright, where is he?
Wait, I have no checkpoints in forest land.
at the walk?
Oh, wait, no, I no, I hit it.
Oh, no, I have the treasure map on.
Okay, never mind.
I was gonna be like, no, don't make me walk.
We're back in the forest land with all these forest landers.
Okay, we need, uh, uh, we need to buy, oh, hey.
Yeah, stuff?
We have premium steel.
We have premium steel!
Oh yeah!
I'll make it worth your while.
And the AN drive for your mech is particularly fun?
Okay, let's buy...
Oh, here's the AN drive!
Alright.
We need that.
Well, we don't really need any of these.
Bring me any rare items you find.
Alright.
Who constructs my stuff?
You guys.
Workshop man!
You have premium steel.
Oh, I need platinum ore.
Fucking, I keep forgetting about the platinum ore shit.
Oh!
Oh wait, we don't need that actually.
Never mind.
Uh...
You're not the upgrade guy?
Do I have enough to upgrade parts?
Upgrade part.
I do!
I finally end up having a steal!
A max level.
Nice.
Uh...
Apparently...
Doesn't matter.
Okay, customize vehicle.
Uh...
Oh my god.
Oh, this...
Okay.
Uh...
what legendary what level is it 25 what the fuck I need to
be level 25 holy shit okay how much do I need for that I'm
like I'm like five levels short okay upgrade vehicle uh okay
I need super hard crocter alloy.
I need a lot of super hard crocter alloy.
Where do I get that, though?
I don't even have it.
You can't even...
What even is it?
What the fuck is the...
What the fuck is a super hard crocter alloy?
And how do I get it?
Oh, level 20 plus is post-game.
So I just have to look at it.
I can just I have to look at the legendary parts And I can't
do anything about That's so cruel That is so fucked up All I
can do is look at it Oh yeah, no I need the battle armor
What is the Oh, is this the A and drive?
Alright, whoa Temporarily boost performance Enables long
range cannon What the cannon?
Enables Oh, this is a long range cannon it i can just look
at it and be like i have this now i can't do anything about
it but i have it all right up we go it's called i shopping
yeah all right this way hello guys all right before we do
anything i need to back you while we're back
all right i'm back i'm back guys Thank you for the super
chats.
Valentina, Duck, Bite, Johnny, Lost Core, Kaz, and...
Oh, my gosh, I need to scroll up.
And Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, we're ready to talk, General Kroa.
You're on my side now.
You made it.
Yeah, it's me.
What's the news?
I've managed to locate King Jam.
Really?
Oh, my God, you're dead.
We're going to find you dead.
I've never lied to a lady since the day I'm...
Whoa.
Damn, we gotta learn from him.
Alright, maybe I was stretching the truth just a little bit.
But cross my heart.
The stuff about King Jam is legit.
Where is my father?
Crump Army Research Lab.
And this information's reliable?
Very much so.
Kroa's subordinates helped us feed false information to the
Forest Land Army.
about the resistance having a plan to rescue the king okay
with the slight exaggeration that they knew exactly where he
was being locked up it spread like wildfire at which point
bread quietly switched out the research lab guards for a
team of his handpicked elites oh so that's how you found out
but are we sure it's not guarded by nerds anymore well
not like we have any choice How will you save him?
By going forward with a fake rescue mission.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
With our with the rest of our army the five people again Oh
my god, another all-out-of-saw Me and my five people Another
all-out-a-saw with five and that's where we'll be going
right misdirections the greatest weapon and outnumbered
force has diversion and infiltration baby same as always
then including us being stuck with the risky part i mean the
three random guys they found on the street
all right we gotta speak all right we did it we finished our
mission that was fast the army research lab where is oh it's
not that far wait never claimed this well i guess i gotta go
here uh which is fast okay i assume this is the cliff guys i
can read maps now i can do i did it okay here we go and then
it is this way okay there should be like a mountain to climb
here oh my god are those premium ores wait that might be a
premium ore right there oh my god we are running dry on the
premium ore careful jam might be spread all over bread by
the time you find it i'm thinking of the super chat then
well thank you thank you i can read maps this is a premium
ore for easy ambushes oh my god it's just regular iron ore
god damn it god fucking why am i gonna do what god damn Oh
my god, do a knight or...
You guys make it sound like there's an enemy up every tree
and in every bush.
Alright, here we go.
That's fine.
I thought there was one behind every rock or doom.
I think I'm going the right way, right?
Yeah, I am.
Thank God.
It'll be a little awkward if I wasn't reading the map right
again.
Wait, so where is the camp?
Ow.
Should be a campsite here?
Where is it?
I have to unlock...
A campsite.
So I have, like, fast travel.
What the fuck is the... Oh, there it is.
It's in front of me.
Nice.
Unlocked it.
Okay, that's all I needed.
Dungeon!
What's this?
There's droves of them.
Based on their state of panic, I bet they're heading to
reinforce vendor base.
Which means now's our chance.
We can't be reckless.
We may have thinned their numbers, but these are bread's
elites.
We should try to infiltrate as covertly as possible.
All right.
Here we go.
They should put those, like, tire spikes here.
That would, like, stop me instantly.
Like, I'm surprised they don't put the tire spikes.
Let's split up so we don't attract attention while sneaking
in.
it's stealth time oh no how the fuck how do i get here oh
shit oh i didn't realize there were people here i was just
walking around being like yay okay i actually did not
realize there were people here so that was awkward okay i'm
gonna oh god damn it it's not fair How did I sneak again?
You probably shouldn't go too crazy inside the base.
Alright.
Guys, I don't remember how to sneak here.
Well, what goes?
Nice.
I carried out 10 stealth attacks, guys.
Alright.
We gotta sneak pack this guy.
We can't catch me if I'm on high ground.
Ah!
Okay, we'll go high ground.
We'll go high ground.
I'm gonna go high ground.
There's only one guy in high ground.
Yeah, the guards die of cringe.
God damn it.
I hate the stealth mission.
Because it makes you restart from the beginning.
Give me mini checkpoints of anything.
Please, I'm stupid.
Where's my journalist mode when it comes to stealth mission?
This is why I'm not a thief anymore, isn't it?
I wish you could like select like difficulties on certain
modes if I had I would fucking suck it in and take
journalist mode for stealth missions 10 that's so many for
you how did you even get 10 that's crazy I would take baby I
will 100% take baby mode for stealth mission I am not afraid
to be I am oh whoa two hours later oh come on come on why
are you walking so far oh there we go that was sort of fun
give me the mini checkpoint I want it now okay I I was
definitely supposed to take high ground there.
Okay, there he is.
Standing there.
There he is.
Wait, there's multiple people there.
How do I scare multiple people?
Do I have to go down?
How the fuck do I scare multiple people?
Does he see me over here?
If I...
Oh.
what no that was so fast i was trying to judge the okay
that's great okay i guess i have to go downstairs now oh my
god that's so not fair there were two people there okay i'm
gonna scare him and i can can i do this is there something
here hide them here?
What the fuck?
What is this place?
What do I do?
What do I do here?
There's something special here?
Oh, wait, what?
Am I supposed to be here?
Like, where am I?
Am I even supposed to be here?
Like, okay.
There's shellplate in here.
I don't know if I'm supposed to go that way.
Or this way.
I'm so confused.
You know what I'm going to do?
I'm risking it.
Here we go.
Oh.
Where am I?
Where did I go?
I don't know.
I don't know where I went.
I'm following the yellow area.
Well, it goes.
I'm going off route.
Oh, god damn it!
That's so unfair.
I don't see that next to me.
Oops, I saw me.
Gotta be more careful.
Okay.
Oh, it is.
It is.
This is what we're meant to do.
We're off the grid!
We're going off grid!
As I follow the yellow marker!
Where does the yellow marker's gone?
No, where do I go when there's no- Oh, there it is.
Okay, this way.
What the fuck?
God damn it!
That's bullshit!
Thank God.
Alright.
Ooh.
Goddamn camper.
Alright, we did it.
That was the route we were supposed to go.
Oh.
Downstairs?
I assume it's downstairs.
Alright, down the stairs we go.
Oh.
Oh, there they are!
Wait, they made it?
How did they do it?
you guys get there before me huh there's no lock on this why
do you guys tell me how did what pathway did you guys go no
wait there is a lock but it has a very unusual shape
whoever's in here must be someone they really don't want
getting out you mean oh jam can you open this i could do
this in my
Where your dad is?
Dad!
He better be, like, super hot if he managed to catch the
fucking demon as a wife.
Or, like, really smart or, like, really nice person.
What the fuck?
As you used to be.
Do you know?
His sister settled for him?
Of course I do, Anne.
There's no way.
I'd fail to recognize my one and only daughter.
I just, it's Peter Griffin.
Just a dad.
Bro, that doesn't even look like a king.
It looks like some fucking office man worker.
That's the most dad dad I've ever seen.
I'm sorry, this has to be an emotional moment.
Bro, he looks like a fucking, like, he's off.
the work at the office he looks like a fucking salary man
not a king he just clocked out he looks like a goddamn
salary worker the dadliest dad it was long ago who rested
most of them i've ever seen just clocked out long ago and he
looked after this too
Lilith's necklace Yes, but Mother is Is she dead?
I heard what happened to her while I was in prison Lilith I
still can't believe He just left his 9 to 5 He's the king
Why you don't be a king It's like business casual
Business casual king Business casual king At least, Bradley
was in uniform.
You do?
And it's real?
Yeah.
We've been gathering it all up to keep bread from getting
his hands on it.
Clocked out of prison time.
This certainly is Aquanium.
Yeah, see?
Whoa, what happened?
What's going on?
hey business king he's business king I don't know what my
body's just moving what's going on no please stop her not
gonna lie everybody no don't go oh no king gem please that's
your daughter why are you so calm oh shit Shit.
Ah, what did?
That kick was on another level.
That scrawny girl actually hurt Prince?
Was she always that strong?
Eh.
Ah.
Is there anything else you wanna say?
M!
John!
Struggle all you like.
Oh!
Why wouldn't he control the demon instead of the fucking
grrr?
I'm not...
Despite your fiend blood, you're still half human.
Oh, he can only control humans.
Oh.
He shot a child.
Oh my god.
Nice one, old man.
What?
Wait, he can't control demons?
How dare you point a gun at me?
I knew it.
Just being around a demon is enough to turn you humans evil.
What?
I must lead you back.
back to the path of righteousness by ridding this world of
that's an angel
whoa there don't go getting any funny ideas now i can have
this foolish fiend wipe you all out before you can even
blink oh my god he is controlling the demon oh my god i gave
him the wrong ideas i mean they're pretty good ideas but
like not to the enemy I don't think he's human he has to be
an angel then because he's like I'm gonna turn you to a path
of righteousness and let's go let Prince handle this but
it's fine just go no I trust you oh my god bro what bro he's
being controlled right now He's like, no, you can't fight
the control.
That's like so much, that's like so much, like, gambler
right now.
Now, let's do this.
I'll blow you into outer space.
You wretched fiend.
Don't worry.
I got a tank.
Give me a sec.
I can't put my tank out.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
I gotta fight you with my fist.
is child here we go take that that's right child so far so
good here oh shit take that I don't remember how to normally
fight but I can smash buttons but I know how to mash that's
fucking right
I Don't know what I'm doing.
I'm just putting that in fucking If Tekken has taught me
anything just be unpredictable
That's fucking right and I can drink water.
I don't know how to drink water guys.
How do I drink water to the?
I don't remember how to hydrate guys how do I hydrate?
Guys, we need a hydrate!
What a winner.
Oh, down.
What do you mean I can't do?
Guys, I can't drink water!
How do I drink water?
Fizz up!
Oh, thank you.
Oh, okay.
Dark energy repair kit.
Oh, no.
I'm gonna...
Wait, how do I, oh, health drink?
Oh, thank God, okay, we got the health drink.
Okay, okay, there we go.
Guys, I figured it out.
I don't know how to drink water, but I figured this out.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
This is, oh, oh, oh, this is awkward.
This is awkward.
Give me a, oh.
Okay.
Okay, we're drinking all the heals right now.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
I don't remember how to drink water.
No, he jumped!
That's not fair.
Oh, God.
That was not fair.
He fucking jumped.
Like, how the fuck was I supposed to deal with that?
This is all the fucking thing was for this.
Oh my god Were these fumbles please I'm trying I was in a
tank for 90% of my life
It's not fair I was literally riding a tank.
I didn't know how to use my fist It is my oh God oh God.
Okay, thank God.
We have another one Nice I should have brought some heels
too, child.
I pluck everything with my face.
I'm okay.
Oh yeah, and all my heels too.
Guys, I'm a bounty hunter, not a fist hunter.
Okay, I was gonna say not fist, I realized maybe I shouldn't
say that.
Well, that picked up.
Wait, what?
Are you with us?
I'm here too, you know.
Wait, where's Anne?
And where's his dad?
What happened?
The last thing I remember, I passed out in that prison.
Rao came back by himself to pull you out of there.
What about you?
I had the important job of securing an escape route and
where is Ann's old man yeah behind you is it my tank wait
who's driving it's my tank Ann said she wanted to give it a
try she'd better not get my tank all yeah no loud in my tank
that was close prince munio had you up against the wall back
there yeah the courties in there he's much too powerful yep
you got that right because he's not human what then what is
he he's an angel he's a demon
No way.
Oh, my plot twist of the century that we read like 30
minutes ago.
No way.
Really?
Long ago, everyone, you have all had to bear so much over
the last 10 years.
again it just looks like it looks like just a regular dad i
like how everybody has like their their outfits are like
very how was it called like um like semi-fantasy mad max
style type deal and then he just looks like some guy from
like 2024 just working from the office Please, get some
rest.
He looks like an Isakai person.
He got Isakai from the office.
We did it!
Reunited with King Jam and Anne.
Yeah, post-apocalyptic outfits.
And then there's fucking King Jam.
Being like, just clocked out.
From my 9 to 5.
Hey!
Just got out from my 9 to 5, guys.
It's great.
Good.
let's see where you had to go where do you have who do we
have to talk to over there how do we get oh okay we go from
here he's the family king he's king of the office he passed
out as soon as he laid down being a prisoner for 10 years he
was a prisoner for 10 years i wish we could let him rest
Kings are about to get ugly.
I doubt bread will take the king's escape sitting down.
We have to protect King Jam and the last of the Aquanium.
But the radar only showed four spots.
The fifth is a mystery.
I know how is his hair per...
They just be like regular...
He's an angel, guys.
The angel was like, time for your regular haircut.
And grooming.
How did he magically keep such a clean hair...
Like, mustache for 10 years?
You mean you know where the Aquinium is?
You know what the Aquinium is?
Not where, but I know who has it.
I gave it to someone I trust dearly.
It's someone you know well, Beelzebub.
Someone I know?
Uh, thief?
The old man?
My dad?
What am I, chopped liver?
Oh, please.
Like you have any idea where it is.
True.
So who is it then?
I knew it!
Ask me the dad.
My dad, the king of demons?
How does that make sense?
I mean, your sister's dead.
It's a long story.
Care to hear it?
Oh my god, yeah.
How did you, like, hook up with his sister?
See, a little over 10 years ago, Lilith happened to be a
part of this.
How did you hook up with his sister?
Tell the child.
Hi, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Do you know anything about this box?
She's not pink Look, you can't just say that You can't just
say why she's not pink See, he's wearing a uniform Now that
looks Okay, the upside, the glasses And the mustache and
that Not really look like a king, but the bottom half Looks
like a king now
Long ago Any idea what this is Now he looks official Oh,
is this a queenium?
I looked around for the key to it, but couldn't find
anything.
He has an age in 10 years.
That's true.
I can't believe, like, they let him have hair dye, too, to
keep his...
Oh, this seems like a long shot.
Oh, that's Lilith.
Could you please pass me your necklace, Lilith?
All right.
Hmm.
Just as I thought.
is a perfect match for the shape of this box's keyhole.
Let's try and open it, darling.
All right.
Oh, she has, like, the...
The fusion earring.
Oh, my.
It's gorgeous.
What do you think it could be?
Oh, my God.
This, this, like, weapon mass destruction shin.
It's so beautiful.
This is Aquanium war.
Aquanium?
That incredibly dangerous material that produces immense
energy?
Lilith has been alive for millennia.
If she recognizes it, I'm sure she's right.
He's a mill hunter.
Perhaps the previous king kept it in the event of an
emergency.
You know, I've heard rumors that Aquanium was the cause of
that explosion in Sandland all those years ago I think we
should hide it respect if bread knew of its existence he'd
surely used it as a weapon so we can't keep it I mean
there's a lot of pressure for him you know for for the
wife's wife to be around for a mill millennia it's got to be
a lot of pressure for him to keep it safe King Lucifer how
did she hide Why does her pointy ears...
Like...
Like, she got everything under disguise with the pointy
ears.
What would the people say about that?
Of course not.
To be honest, she has a point.
I can't imagine a safer place to keep it.
And don't you worry about the key either.
I'll keep it as close as ever.
Then she dies.
And that's what happened.
Did your father tell you about any of this?
Did you know about this thief?
We finally figured out what she looked like!
This is the first I'm hearing of this.
Wait, how does she have blonde hair?
Wait a minute!
Anne has blonde hair, Lilith has red hair, and Jam has black
hair.
Wait a minute!
I just... I just...
You were ruining it.
Wait a minute!
Something doesn't add up.
I just noticed.
Wait a minute, Ann!
I can't believe my necklace was the key to the Aquanium
chest.
It's fucking weird shaped.
So, like, we had a feeling it was a lock for something.
It's in safe hands.
So we've been going around collecting Aquanium like mad for
nothing?
Well, it's still a dangerous maturity.
Yeah, I was going to say.
We have to find the Aquanium for the other people.
Just by using it for its explosive properties.
So there's no change in our to-do list even with my father,
Freed.
We'll get rid of that stupid angel and get the Aquanium
back.
Which stupid angel?
Wait, there's more than one?
Okay.
Mooniel's an angel?
I mean, what?
Was she not there?
Hmm.
Makes sense.
Lady Lilith wouldn't lose to a human.
Mother.
Well, we'll need to replenish our energy if we want to
succeed.
Oh.
Oh, she was in the tank.
Oh, yeah.
I'll take a spot on the floor, too.
I almost forgot she was in the tank.
I thought she was with us.
I always assumed she's always with us for some reason.
Even though she was driving.
Even though we all heard her driving the tank.
I was like, she's with us, guys.
Oh, wait.
There's stuff here.
Okay.
Hit the hay.
How do I?
Oh, I have to go back.
Wait, where is?
How do I get up there?
way oh it's this way okay i was gonna say how do i get to
the sleeping quarters okay i'm gonna rob you guys poop my
stuff now my friend's the queen i or the princess i mean
she's practically the queen now so i can rob you guys
because my that's my friend's stuff wait how did you get
here what weren't you downstairs oh prince are you going to
sleep already Yeah.
Yeah, I am.
Good night.
What was that?
Oh, yeah, she's my niece.
Yeah, that's right.
That means I can steal everything.
Everything that's here is mine.
What happened?
Yeah, what happened?
Oh, now he's in the outfit?
Now he's not a... Oh, my God, finally!
Okay, now he sort of fits in.
Gone!
Are you sure?
Maybe you just...
put it down somewhere that's not it i left it on my pillow
but now i can't find it anywhere on your pillow you took it
off what now he's gone epi's gone epi who is epi what how
could you let him oh it's the general i didn't let him
escape he just got away Take it all.
That's the same thing, you idiot!
And the day after King Jam told us what it does.
The timing's far too convenient to be coincident.
There's a spy.
Do you think it was Epi who stole the necklace?
It has to be, because Epi wasn't there to listen to us.
Knowing Epi, I wouldn't put it past him.
There's a spy here.
Could be you.
It could be me.
It could even be.
I'll give it a shot.
I could think of a few routes he could have taken.
Prince, we're going back to Sandland.
No!
What the fuck?
I was only in four steps for like 10 seconds.
The first place they'll go is Demon Village.
So, my dad's there.
He'll take care of it.
When it comes to Aquanium, we can't take anything.
No, Rarul.
Not.
Sounds like a waste of time to me.
Why do we keep going back to Sandland?
I thought we're free from Sandland.
And then they put me back into the sand.
Every time.
You can never leave sand land.
Okay, we gotta get his HP up, that's for sure.
Oh, I have four skill points.
I was not paying any attention.
We're gonna raise the darkness attack.
And we're gonna raise the darkness.
And we're not gonna do anything regarding the rock.
Because I have no idea how to use the rock.
my god we can finally upgrade you and recover hp increases
okay we need to increase that and then limit time boost
consumes no energy oh that's really good i'm gonna fucking
upgrade all that and stuff recover his hp for bills above
vehicles yes parent breakdowns and other stats insanely
instantly reloads oh instant reload ammo reduces cooldown
for a quick reload nice okay that's really good.
Finally, actual useful skills.
Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's back to the sand.
Where's the mission?
So I want to go back to the sand.
Oh, there it is.
Is that it?
No, that's the flowers.
Oh, I always forget about the flowers.
Wait, where is the mission?
Oh, it's over here.
The demon village.
God, it's so far.
Dad, I'm home.
I'm home, Dad.
Did you miss me?
I brought your...
Uh, grandmese?
No, your grandchild!
I brought your grandchild!
Wait, it's not supposed to be like this?
The Farisland army were this quick?
Oh, I assumed it was supposed to be like this, because it's
like, hell.
Looks like they're still inside.
Are you kidding me?
I thought it was supposed to be like that because it's hell.
I didn't realize it was not supposed to.
Gremlin, what's going on?
A human piloted bot dropped bug monsters.
Oh, it's a bug thing.
I've never seen creatures like them in Sandland before.
Yeah, but it's where the demons live.
I'm hurt.
attackers went for the underground ruins yeah you go on
ahead prince i'll join you once i get patched up okay i have
to go this way oh my god i i honestly thought that's what
hell was supposed to look like are you okay slime slime are
you okay oh my god he's gonna evaporate
No, that's a different guy.
Alright, it's this way.
Prince, we're sorry.
We couldn't hold down the fort.
These bug monsters dropped down from the sky and steamrolled
us.
Oh no, we gotta...
We gotta hope that's okay.
Is up down?
Yeah, up is down.
Okay, I always have to remember if up is down.
Dad, are you okay, Dad?
Dad!
Sorry, I was trying to see it.
I forgot to run.
Dad!
I have your grandchild here.
It's the last piece of lift that we have.
What are you doing?
Attack him as one!
Quick, quick, quick, quick, quick.
Damn it.
The final piece of Aquanium.
It's so close.
Bruh.
Wait, then who's bread?
Is bread also an angel?
I'm already using it, but I can't make him fudge so much as
a finger.
Yeah, because we got a baby angel.
Baby angel.
I recognize that spell.
You're that bungling angel who broke my widescreen TV years
ago.
I thought I tore off your wings and flung you into the
sunset Not the widescreen TV.
Oh, yeah.
He was like the cyborg guy for a lot.
Sorry.
He's so forgettable as a character Were you covered in
wounds because of oh Yes, that's right.
This fruit had beaten me black and blue Okay, you broke his
TV like you you broke into his home and broke his tv like
like and he's a bad guy for our showdown fool what the fuck
he wait is he mad his revenge is based off the tv he he
started an entire war because he broke up guys tv
What a story That's the plot Let's see how you
Pour the TV
Millions of people died Water was Was withheld from entire
country Because an angel Beat up got beat up Because he
broke a devil demon's TV He killed Lilith!
Dad,
no!
It was a smart TV, don't you?
You don't understand.
Millions of people die because of a TV.
No.
Such toughness.
I never dreamt the king of demons could be this bro.
This guy's literally the king of demons.
What do you mean, Brad?
Where'd that stupid angel go?
His favorite show is gonna air He got the wait Oh, no, I
have a divine one.
What?
But now earn sealed away Oh
Not the ceiling earn Where did he get that?
The bird no
Now I'll just go ahead and Give me my dad back you jerk He's
gonna eat a what the fuck
He just ate him I did it Lucifer's been sealed away What the
fuck
and while i'm at it i might as well get rid of his bread too
huh what you just eat lucifer it's that easy stand back
everyone you can just eat lucifer oh no not again not round
two oh no This is bad guys.
I was not ready for I was not ready for round two of this.
I did not stock up No I didn't stock up
Guys I didn't stock up on his Oh this I'm so fucked Guys how
do you block again guys?
I don't remember I thought I thought I thought I'd be using
my tank what is this
oh god what do you mean I can't use my tank
oh god oh god where are my allies okay nice archangel my
butt you little runt oh my god there's other attacks i
figured it out so far so good oh shit i figured it out
there's other attacks guys oh my god guys i figured out how
to roll Oh my god, let's go!
I figured out the other movesets!
Guys, I'm doing better!
Holy shit!
The tutorial at the last pause, let's fucking go!
Look, after getting spoiled, what take?
I'm playing Tekken.
I beat your ass, child.
Hey, get back here.
You literally won because you ate my dad.
What the fuck?
Why is he Urple?
Looks like all the other Equiniums.
Why did you make an Urple bug?
It looks like the prize is ours.
Then, let's be on our way.
Are you sure you trust the insect men to finish them off?
It doesn't matter if they manage to survive temporarily.
After all the trouble they've put us through, it would serve
them right to know true despair by witnessing Garum rise
into the sky in their final moment.
What the fuck is Garum?
Wait, the aquarium walks away Looks like we've got to take
care of these guys first Can I bring my tank now?
Am I allowed to have my tank?
Oh, thank God.
Thank you.
Oh Thank God.
Oh My God Thank you.
Why could I bring this earlier?
okay not gonna lie why could i not bring this earlier to the
fight this does not make sense holy shit he's literally just
one hit yeah like the insect men are so scary all right who
are bro looking like salazar from resident evil for dr
crabberry thank you for the super chat a guy does so you
can't trust it i was like what is this little twerp doing
kick his ass
out of luck
we're totally sunk how could they have taken out my dad i'm
king now gone and grandpa too bro you just found out he's
your grandpa
i'm sorry about lady lilith But the King of Demons has not
been taken out.
Yeah, because I'm king now.
From what Munio said, that urn only seems capable of sealing
Lucifer away.
The King of Demons may be trapped, but he should still be
alive.
Probably.
So we take the urn back from that brat.
We can still fix this.
How do we take it?
It's literally getting digested right now.
He has to use the bathroom.
do angels need to use the bathroom we'll find out soon for
starters we've got to let the trick camp guys know about
this all right i'll contact him right away what do we have
to do go back to the camp all right we're gonna find out if
angels need to use the bathroom what do you mean toky no
it's an honest question How are we going to get the urn out?
No, not our place.
Let's leave the big decisions to King Jam and Longo.
I'll go and tell Father then.
And I'll speak with Longo.
All right.
We gotta go speak with everybody.
If it's something rare, I'll...
All right.
Whoa!
That's a lot of stuff.
That's not tank related.
I don't need any of these.
Okay, we need to buy...
I'll make it worth your while.
We need to buy HP.
We're running out of heels.
Alright, buy.
Okay, repair kit.
Repair kit plus.
Okay, we're gonna buy this.
And then we need to buy health serum.
Because we don't have that anymore.
Oh, we have so much money!
That's good.
Alright, got replenished on this.
I guess I'll...
We'll buy firepower.
Oh, wait.
No, actually, let's get max firepower.
All right, there we go.
Thank you.
No problem.
All right, we got to talk to him.
Up we go.
Okay, climb up the ladder, bells.
Climb up the ladder, bells.
Okay, we got to tell Longo.
All right, it's come down to this.
We must put everything on the line to stop Garum's
reactivation.
Is it even possible?
Yeah, it's possible?
This is the most destructive weapon in history.
Which once sunk an entire continent?
The Flying Fortress guard.
Oh yeah, Flatlands.
And there's only one way inside it.
That's a giant hole.
I know, I was like, what the fuck?
You have to make your way to the lowest level of the Masala
dig site where it's buried.
And use the tunnel to its entrance there.
But with bread and moonio already headed for garum Jesus
Sorry, I had to look at something We must be prepared to
make sacrifices on our side Though any member of the
resistance
the rebel army there's no more frightening enemy than one
that doesn't know fear doesn't quite ring true coming from
the man who won that war i lost that war as badly as you did
yeah nobody won in that war literally an entire cotton that
is gone as old dogs needed to learn new tricks eh i should
hope so
all right then we got a Talk to...
We're gonna talk to whoever's over there.
I guess, like, the dad?
Office dad?
Office king?
Office king!
I don't know why I would tell you about what's going on.
So even Lucifer has been bested.
There's not a safe place left in this world.
Then we'll make one.
That's what we've been fighting for, right?
Hmm.
Though considering how many times I've almost lost hope,
maybe that's not very good.
convincing coming from me the people ash thank you to the
super chat thank you thank you is jokey bird from bump land
yeah that's where i'm from i wish lilith could have seen the
person you've become father let's give them some alone time
yeah this might be the last time they see each other huh huh
what what wait what do you mean by that this one Nothing.
The last time, who's gonna die?
What do you mean by that?
Somebody gonna die?
Oh my gosh, I couldn't go down the ladder.
Alright, who else do I need to talk to?
Can I tell the swimmer?
Huh?
It's just you guys?
The rest of the resistance left only a little while ago.
Under your orders, Lungo.
Where they left?
No.
It was their own decision.
Nothing could dissuade them.
Are they running away?
Are they joining us?
Soldiers, it's to go where there's fire.
Oh, okay, they're joining us.
I thought they, like, left us and they ran away.
I'll be leaving soon myself.
King Jam, I'll leave this place in your capable hands.
If there's anything I can do, no.
This is your fight.
I'll be praying for yourself.
safety swimmers move out all right yeah good luck to you you
too we'd better get going as well and i need you to come
back alive i'll be fine whose daughter do you think i am she
can talk to Have we even used like her animal powers like
other than that one time like I feel like The fact that she
could talk to animals but we only used it once Beelzebub Rao
I won't ask you to protect her just try not to let her be
you killed all the animals Who is she gonna talk to?
Understood.
She talked to the flying Dino, too.
Did you...
Alright, let's see.
Can I upgrade anything?
I don't know.
Just double checking.
Can I upgrade my...
Yeah, everything's maxed out now.
Oh, customized.
Alright, apparently these don't matter.
This gun is, like, the best overall, so I'm not gonna worry
then.
i'm just surprised i haven't got any of these any better
stuff here bro these guys uh 25 thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you i had a rough day tip after watching
your stream i feel better now thank you so much and good
luck with the rest of stream thank you thank you that super
chat 25 i hope you feel i'm glad you feel a lot better now
and i'm glad to cheer you up thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you all right here we go we go straight to
it the final hours, the Sandland.
Alright, it's down there.
Is it all the way down there?
Alright, we're just gonna jump down.
Oh my god, it is.
Alright, I can do this.
Ooh!
Okay, never...
Okay.
Let me do the proper way, I guess.
I guess the game did not want me to jump down.
How the fuck do I get there okay i'm trying to figure out
how to get there i guess from here to a flip something about
this place is putting me on edge yeah same here be prepared
for a fight at any moment how the do i get down what the
hell you know it must be dangerous get down from here i was
any good at sensing things like that too that bad okay all
right apparently not okay apparently gravity is saying no
today what about from here okay I'm just trying to test the
limits Guys, I just wanted to know what which one would
Grabby has to have a stopping point at some somewhere Don't
keep these I don't know, I just thought Grabby was gonna
stop working They're forced you to listen To the tile This
is a more developed Military technology One upside of the
Royal Army's iron fist is that it didn't need to fight many
actual wars only a small fraction of the royal army was
dedicated to making technological advancements oh so that's
why wait so forestland was always at war with others and
then sandland just existed it was only at war with itself
it's kind of ironic that it takes war to push forward
sense oh hey there's a stop here all right let's see what
the fuck are these lizards doing here there's so many oh my
god okay give me a sec let me loot give me a sec oh god oh
god okay it followed me home here we go that's right you
made a big mistake you made a big fucking mistake that's
fucking right that's right not to go in so deep that you
can't touch the bottom Prince so I think of a super chat
thank you thank you more dokey house seven we're almost I
don't know if we're close to done but I think we're almost
done I think we're at the final arc now not long now supreme
commander Rosetta?
Yeah.
What are you doing here?
You don't deserve to be on flat land.
There is something I would like to confirm with you.
You once said if we were able to reactivate Garum, it
wouldn't be used against the Resistance.
Please tell me that is still true.
King Jam and Princess Anne are among them after all.
Oh, she's gonna turn to our side.
former princess garum shall not be fired within our borders
however if they flee to sandland and continue to oppose us
that's that's not part of the deer she's like her childhood
friend you're telling me you still haven't found the
resistance flush them out and burn them to ashes what do you
mean like he was there What are you doing here?
What is he?
You know where the resistance...
He literally lived there.
I thought I ordered you to command the front lines, Epi.
Came from.
With Garum functional once more, we can now wipe out the
resistance with a single shot.
Surely I don't need to trouble myself with something so
prosaic.
Remind me which one of us is the commanding officer?
Yes, yes, very well.
He has more medals.
Where are your medals, Rosetta?
Oh my god.
He insulted our queen.
Oh my god, that's so fucked up.
Oh, this is some scar shit right here.
I'm just gonna...
Eliminate them!
Woo!
He not as fast though.
The nerve of him.
I know, right?
So fucked up.
Wow.
What an army.
What could I possibly do?
What are they gonna do?
Slide up to me?
Okay.
Goodbye.
What is that?
What defense?
The world's in serious trouble.
If something like that takes off.
Nothing's gonna stop us now.
What defense they have.
Oh, shit.
Okay, it's okay.
I made it through.
It's okay.
My bike is okay.
Don't worry.
Oh.
my god we're here how did they do it wow how did she do it
oh shit we have to claim that okay we have to claim that
real fast all right this is a little awkward give me a sec
guys we need to claim the little we need a claim okay don't
worry that's not gonna hurt us oh my bike no i got greedy I
wanted to claim that the dead.
No, I got to do that again.
Oh my god.
I have to do that again I got greedy No That's okay.
I can dodge all of this again.
Oh No, not again What is that I got so greedy.
I wanted to get the checkpoint the water I wanted to get the
water that's okay like they're not really a threat i
literally just i i don't understand like are am i supposed
to stop am i supposed to beat those mechs up like i don't
know why do that way i can just ride past it okay i wanted
to claim this yeah i got the camp give me a sec guys that
claim the camp i did it It's okay.
Oh, God, that's not okay.
It's all right riding past it again.
Oh, guys, I got it.
I got the water.
We did it, guys.
Him again?
Hey, it's half dash.
Don't worry.
I got it.
a strong and oh god god wait a minute wait what why is it so
strong where is he where do you go oh there he is holy it
has so much hp now oh my god yeah he has lasers too he's 3.0
he's at his 3.0 debut oh god oh he is strong I need to use
the explosive lasers yeah yeah yeah yeah I need to make sure
I line it up though properly wait where did he go where the
fuck did he go oh there he is okay on guard Prince okay no
are you fucking dodging explosive lasers ah that's actually
bullshit he actually dodged explosive lasers i can't believe
it i are you serious
i can't believe he dodged it he's so good he walked to the
left
i can't believe it he walked to the left
how does he do that that should be illegal
oh my god i still can't believe he walked to the left and
like fucked me over that's fine i literally can just stay
here he's I said that should be illegal There you go All
right, oh I should aim body you're right I should have used
my aim but There you go Oh, oh, we're having again.
Oh wait, I shouldn't oh god, okay Okay, watch this.
Can't dodge this now.
BOOM!
I take like 100 damage, but can't dodge this!
I'll let daddy's girl Rosetta finish you.
While I watch from a safe distance.
Wait, what?
I'm gonna fight Rosetta now?
Yay!
Level- Alright.
Where am I supposed to go?
How the fuck do I get there?
That came from here?
Where did I come from?
Where do I go?
Where do I come from?
Oh, this way.
Alright.
What was going on with Half-Stash?
Yeah.
What was going on with him?
I'm just gonna shoot him from the distance.
I am no need for me to be there say all right get over here
oh my god how you still alive all right you guys you guys
are gonna get there soon i believe don't worry you're gonna
get there soon there we go nice these guys are tough all
right main defense unit wait what tough okay okay be so but
we we've been This has been a breeze so far Okay, don't
worry, I have to keep them from activating guard It's our
only hope is it dead nice and then we'll get rid of him And
then we'll get rid of hit this might be a little overkill,
but that's okay Shooting the the cannon might be just a
little overkill just a little bit What's over here?
I feel like I should go here though Okay, it's nice that I
can use this from afar.
All right now they're getting closer But like it's so nice
that I can use this from afar like it still works
You're gonna now reload And then Peep peep peep oh, okay,
he's dead peeppepepe All right now where do I go Sound there
wait, I could just drove down I did not have the oh guys i
made a mistake i did it guys do not just drive down guys do
not just drive down guys don't just drive down we've learned
we can learn from mistakes all right all right gravity has
sort of forsaken What the fuck?
We're going to do a little pistol gun.
Uh, we need to heal again.
Alright.
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but like, uh, in
this world, there's something that we like to call gravity.
And sometimes it is a good idea not to not to let gravity
win.
Alright, nice.
and he's gonna get rid of these smaller guys too wait is he
dying wait but they told me I don't kill that guy he said
fading away his life is fading away did I just kill him at
no I should know it's not me it's my tank all right get on
this side okay you
Okay, then...
Oh, wait, I didn't get rid of the tank yet.
Okay, now I got rid of the tank.
And...
Alright.
Easy, there's more?
Holy shit!
How much money do they have?
Why couldn't I use this to invade Sandland?
all right nice feels like they could have done so much by
using all this to invade sandland all right we're almost
there why is it so slow am i not using my i have so many
questions rosetta looks like there's nobody left because
that is not worth that much hey rosetta Surrender now, Anne.
I'm gonna eat my sandwich while you guys talk it out,
ladies.
The Supreme Commander is preparing to activate Garm as we
speak.
You have no hope of victory.
Oh, yeah?
I have a tank.
I mean, you have a bigger tank, but I have a tank too.
Ooh, that's a lot of sauce on my sandwich.
You should know I'm too stubborn to change.
that's true the end that I know is stubborn a sore loser and
a cry baby whoa whoa you never would go easy on me back when
we play games together I'm not cry baby oh I would I'm not
you were just so weak that you've still lost well not
anymore.
We'll find out.
Oh, shit.
Hope you're not expecting me to start going easy on you now.
Wait, we're starting?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I thought the cutscene would be longer.
I thought the cut.
So, I'm in the tank.
I'm in the tank.
I'm in the...
Okay, okay, I'm in the tank now.
I'm in the tank now.
Okay,
that was scary, but I'm in the tank now.
I'm in the tank.
Don't get a run over here.
I wasn't, I didn't know if she was gonna start that had a
longest time in the country.
Let's see!
How fucking...
How was I supposed to know?
She almost rode killed me.
No, she...
She almost did.
Holy shit.
She did not let me chill.
She was just like...
She did not just ready, set, go.
She just went, go.
You know how they're like, we're gonna start at three?
It's like they start at one.
Oh god, oh god, that was a lot of damage.
That was, hey, let's just heal a little bit.
Okay, I almost got a taste of my own medicine, yeah.
Okay, Raul, get back in here, Raul.
Raul, get back in here!
Okay.
Lizard!
Alright.
Oh, it's almost down.
It's almost down.
Almost one more hit.
One more hit.
Okay, two more hits.
Maybe.
Okay, maybe three.
Oh my god.
We're almost there!
Oh, it's looking at me.
I don't like it when it looks on me like that oh i got the
boost the nitro the nitro nice
finally enough of this sand down afraid i can't do that if
you want to get past it will have to be over my dead body no
rosetta it doesn't have to be this way
else are you doing i'm grateful for your long lifespan
themed it will give me the chance to kill you in my next
life am i gonna slap her oh oh is
her skull okay
bro i guys i
Brain damage!
That is...
Okay.
I like how...
Alright, we're gonna not pay attention to that, I guess.
Like...
Oh my god.
That would have fucking...
That is worse than a concussion!
It should be...
Oh my god.
We're actually thinking of the Super Chat.
Thank you.
The deadly forehead.
finger flip oh my god what the fuck did i just witness that
like that is like that oh she gets into a coma that's lucky
if she's not a vegetable by the end
i thought she was gonna slap her a slap would have like at
least she'd survive freaking fiends how are you alive how do
you not brain damage pity what are you doing here no never
mind that doesn't matter after them you have to
such agitation i'll help you relax for a very long time what
This is no time for games.
Oh.
Epi.
You.
I'll give you a glorious death in battle to expunge the
dishonor of your defeat.
Did she die?
She died from a bullet and not the head flick?
You'd prefer that to getting a lecture from your father,
wouldn't you?
Her weakness was guns.
She died from a bullet, but not the fucking flick through
the head.
Oh, no.
We've got to move.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm just gonna grab this guy.
Where are you?
I think I punched him.
I can't see, but I assume I punched him.
I cut but it's my one weakness no I can't fit as fuck this
I'm just gonna ride my way through oh my god okay we gotta
repair this bike at least serve her one hell of a flick
still better wake up than pure clock tuck thank you in the
suit chat thank you we're so close stupid
What the fuck?
Let's get on the bike.
The bike is the fastest.
What?
Oh, it activated!
Amazing.
This is amazing.
Indeed it is.
With this, our army will control the entire...
world and yours truly has risen to the boast of succumbed in
command now no one in the world can defy me he's like so
insignificant like this story
we were too late can someone just get him a new tv Run away!
I can't stand it.
How dare those worms put up such a fight?
That does it.
Soldiers, ready the main cannon.
Target, our lower port.
The main cannon?
That hasn't been tested yet.
How do they know how to run this?
This is their first time here.
not even like educated to fucking run the death star like
yes sir preparing to fire main cannon power literally first
day on the job they're like we haven't we haven't even we
don't even know which buttons those are what are those
buttons what manual this one ship has been out of commission
for like hundreds of years
energy at maximum initiating countdown 30 seconds
are you alive you got shot and brain damage he's look she's
alive sorry the flick was like got her to like 1 2 HP the
gunshot got her to 1 HP you know like Pokemon Stand it
because of their love for you.
That's what happened the power of love
She's crazy crazy danger
Oh my god, I think guys I think if he's dead
They're not serious.
Yeah, I don't think they get over on that.
Why?
That's the dad?
Have we learned nothing?
Wait, is Epi her dad?
Okay.
Oh, bread.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I was like, okay, it's okay.
Bread's the dad.
Okay, that's a lot better I was like, God's so fucked up if
that thing was the father.
Okay, bread's the dad.
All right.
Oh Why moonium we can't fire Garum on our own territory I
don't remember making any such promise besides justice
requires something guys Like when we imprisoned King Jam
didn't protest then
can't believe it all this happened because you got beat up
by Lucifer for breaking his TV nearly Sandland had no water
because he fucking broke into Lucifer's house
princess thank goodness all four of you made it back for the
TV if the cannon was aimed towards us we wouldn't have made
it and the others we lost many of us in that attack who died
uh mr row who is that in your car general rosetta
what longo i can she's a childhood friend we're gonna be
roommates
And they were a roommate.
I've done what I can.
Now, the rest is up to her.
Look after her.
Hey, can you check her brain?
See if there's brain activity?
I will
They didn't even take off her uniform How are we giving her
medical assistance?
She's still wearing maybe blood Soaked uniforms in there
right now Like she was on the ground Take off the uniform
And put her in something else The jury's gonna get into her
wound Is her skull in one?
That's a good question Is her skull in one piece after
everything I did?
Like save our queen all right all right let's see yeah here
we go oh yeah go this way all right but oh i was gonna say i
need to use the bathroom but i guess we'll do this cutscene
i don't know but yeah then you can count on her making it
she's always been a tough girl after all perhaps we can get
some useful information from her once she wakes are you
going to keep fighting I've been thinking maybe you could
the king was not fighting like he was just here at the base
I'm not saying we don't stand a chance but we've lost so
many allies who do we lose like soldier number three with no
face and name from here is the one thing i cannot do okay
where zeta lived oh yeah move to spinos i can tax from
people homeland what kind of king would i be besides we
still have allies here and i've 10 years i've kept them
waiting it's only fair that i wait for
his troops already know where you are they could obliterate
this entire region if they fire garam's main cannon at you
that only makes it all the more important that i not leave
as long as i'm here supreme commander bread might hesitate
to fire on this location even during those long years he
kept me imprisoned he always treated me with total respect
yeah okay they're going assuming that bread can control the
psychotic angel.
My father!
Soldier number three did so much for us, Doki!
How could you say that?
He was my Oshi!
Every person born on this planet has a duty they must
fulfill.
Mine is to be a stout tree under which all those seeking
refuge here can find shelter.
You did nothing for ten years.
Like...
You must go fulfill your own.
You're talking about this responsibility when you were stuck
in prison for ten years but
just listen to your heart ann that is where you're sure to
find your answer that's my girl go on
king james is a truly wise ruler we're gonna be heroes he's
got nothing before we go with the final arc can you use the
bathroom hover back guys we're almost done i think i know i
said that like an hour ago but this time we're almost done
I am back I'm back guys Give me a sec Just gonna adjust some
stuff real fast Oh What the heck Why do I have like so many
Oh okay Nevermind So I need it I was like Why do I have so
many messages Oh it's about the Oh yes It was about the
Anime expo stuff Also Thank you for the super chat Dark star
Bye Ginger, Risa, Hiro, Dark, Duck, Hey, Johnny, Medi, Kaz,
and Alan.
Thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I guess you didn't know.
We're going to have an extra guest for my karaoke at an
expo, and it's going to be with Yuson.
Yuson's going to be a bonus guest at my karaoke.
And we're going to have some duets and some solo songs.
So, yes, I'm getting carried.
I'm going to be on Yuson's backpack as they carried me in
karaoke.
but yeah that was what the message I was like what the fuck
20 messages why do I have 20 messages
um so yeah I had to double check on like you're just talking
about the announcement for it um all right and what do you
want to say
it's odd I've been at war my whole childhood I should
remember all the scared and lonely times here yet somehow
all my memories oh yeah okay i gotta buy stuff okay i'll buy
healed
i am going to fight you're not fighting you're just staying
in my tank and repairing it my father said that he would
stay here and protect everyone who supported him that's why
i want to be a beacon of hope for all of those who protected
me I take it you found your answer.
The two of them are truly the sword and shield of forest
land.
What about what?
What about me?
I did so much.
What do you mean?
What about me?
It's not always about you.
It's not me, me, me, me, me.
I don't know.
Literally protected for his land!
And we'll need the world armies help for that.
I don't believe it for his land!
And that's old Mooniel too.
And we have to rescue the king of demons.
Are we going back to Sandland?
Prince, you didn't forget about that, did you?
No, no, no, of course not.
We forgot about our dad?
That got ward in front of us?
Can't believe it.
Oh, there ain't Raoul.
I gotta restock my stuff.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, we need a buy.
Okay, we have all the health, so we need, like, repair kits.
Oh, my God, we need so many repair kits.
Okay, we got repair kits.
But let's grab some strength serum, and then some firepower,
too.
We'll grab firepower and armor up.
Alright.
Gabriel, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's your birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Thank you.
Happy birthday, dear Gabriel.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah!
Woo!
Alright.
Let's see.
I feel like I don't need to upgrade anything.
Unless I have like...
Do I have a machine gun?
I have a better machine gun after finally after years?
Let's check.
Dragons.
Nope.
Still the same old machine gun.
And you guys say my laser is like the best laser out of all
of these.
So I believe you guys.
Oh my god.
But this one's 324.
Guys.
This one has 324.
Do I not take it?
It's like double.
Guys.
Is it not worth it?
But Nucleus here, though.
But number big.
Oh, wait.
But the number is big.
Number big.
Can it charge?
I gosh not.
Okay.
Oh, the charge shot is bigger.
Oh, it doesn't count the charge shot.
Okay.
trust you guys I will be back father long I'll be back guys
and roommate you can't leave if the resistance flees to sand
land father said he'll wipe you out with Garum.
Red will attack anyway.
Whether we go or not.
No.
That's not what my father wants.
Come on, Rosetta.
If she's talking a little slower than usual, we know why.
We might have fixed her bones, but I don't think you can get
back brain cells.
Very lonely.
Lonely?
He has no friends?
wait I'm going to take we can't let you go before you answer
some questions he's just mister he murdered thousands of
people but he was so lonely you don't understand he has no
friends I just want more time time I should have died I back
at the oh they should have died like at least two times but
that tyke didn't finish me whoa who are you calling a tyke
whoa okay and told me all we really needed was to take the
time to talk to each other who wrote that why that specific
word I think I'm finally beginning to see what she meant Hmm
I'd like to know what you think Beelzebub Yeah but why did
why couldn't he say kid No Like Why did they say it like
that I don't care It sounds like a different way Whatever
it's worth I and what do you think ann
i want her to come with me guys remember roommates they're
just very good friends you
know how the saying goes put water on an old fire but logs
on a new what does that mean
What?
Let's let Ari know that we're going back to Spino.
I'm not sure it's a great idea for me to go into town.
Yeah, considering you shelled the place.
Thief, why don't you lend her the Santa costume?
Okay, this is not fair.
Like, okay, Rosetta has the same hair color as her dad.
But, and...
I'm not lending my paper.
a costume to a human that's all i'm saying it's fine i'll
just try not to draw too much attention sorry for the way
you guys are like it's anime jeans guys it's anime jeans
let's ask around spino to see how sandland is doing yeah
santa exists in sandland
oh here we're in gar or something I already forgot the
ship's name.
Can someone tell me why we're stopping here?
To issue a demand of surrender to Sandlands King.
Should he fail to comply?
What do you need to sign for?
You're letting them surrender?
Oh, fine.
Just take over somewhere else.
There's nothing here.
Come on, move it.
Set course for the demon village.
We'll smash it to pieces!
but the supreme commander ordered us to the capital that can
wait we're counting yeah the legion to the ground first that
TV really fucked him up we show the royal army garum in
action surely they'll realize how futile resistance is
imagine all the glass you commit dokey very well nothing
wrong with saving the best for They have dirt.
The Sandlot's so poor.
They're all so poor.
they just got water.
Yes.
They got watered last week.
That army's gigantic battleship is floating over the dam.
Damn it.
So Garum's entered Sandland.
Oh, my.
I just don't understand.
What's so great about Sandland?
Everybody wants to leave sad lad I saw the news on TV what
do we do we're gonna have to fight We're not even technology
did technological dip.
Oh my gosh.
I'm sorry English is my first language We don't even have
the technology.
They're more advanced than we are There's no way to know
what a battles outcome will be until it's fought You can use
sad to make for TV.
January.
All right.
You're still alive.
Walk slower, please.
It's like fucking...
Civ.
Right.
Like civilization.
We're like the cavemen and they're like fucking making a
nuclear bomb.
All right.
Time to talk to the general.
All right, all right.
They can build sad.
They had... I don't know if you guys noticed, but Forrest
Land has a beach.
Oh, he was over in the car, uh, in the garage.
Okay.
I was like, where did he go?
What?
General Array, wait!
Don't be racist!
Move away.
That woman's a Forrest Land Army, General!
Oh!
Ah!
Not anymore!
Rosetta is no longer our enemy!
I'm not sure.
What do you mean I'm not sure?
At the moment I don't have a plan behind it yet, nor would I
if I didn't.
What do you mean I'm not sure?
Let me assure you.
For the time being, my priority is stopping my father.
Do you really expect me to trust an enemy, General?
Huh?
do you have like a fucking mini heart attack there there's
no way that your wound could have healed yet oh that's why
he was limping who do you think wounded me her brigade I
know how you feel but she's not I'm not sure a bang no yeah
far as I can tell she doesn't have any bad intentions that's
so Deadpool thank you the super chat thank you thank you
Doki that made her confused give her a break thank you thank
you is everybody injured who's like not injured where are
you going i feel like i fought more and i'm okay i don't
want to invite undue suspicion by making you worry i'm
spying on your war council
first i'd like to hear everyone's thoughts
chat with everyone out the battle with that flying fortress
long enough their Aquanium energy will have to run out at
some you mean like hundreds of thousands of years because
the Aquanium still worked in those old wreckage true but how
are we supposed to survive long yeah that's not a great idea
well realize you hadn't really thought this through that's a
terrible idea I was just taking my time thinking this is why
we shouldn't have talked to everybody our only option is to
attack so swiftly that the enemy isn't given any time to
think yeah they should have given her the Santa outfit bread
would be willing to talk if we could get Rosetta to contact
him if he'd agree to a meeting I'd speak with him in person
even if okay we're not going alone in an arm of an angel on
their side of reason he would have listened to King Jam
that's a fair point maybe fighting is the only way I just
hope we can settle this without getting civilians of either
country involved all right apparently everybody had bad
ideas so we should not listen to everybody it's main cannon
is unimaginably powerful they could easily destroy the whole
world if they wanted to to make things worse tanks to hit
and even if they could it's so massive that they wouldn't
leave a dent the only options i can think of are to take
control of the command center or somehow immobilize it then
how about we bust in there and kick their butts right wait
so the general had the only good idea because he's a general
by the way so he's used to making up making plans then why
the fuck did we get input from you two we'd need an airplane
to get up there Royal Army hadn't lost its cargo airship.
And whose fault is that?
In any case, a plane as slow as the cargo airship would end
up riddled with holes before it got anywhere near.
This is a team effort.
We need an airplane fast enough to dodge anti-air missiles.
Come to think of it.
We'll have a plane.
How exactly did the Forest Land Army transport that Aquanium
from the Inno Base?
what do you mean we used a radar device attuned to Aquanium
to detect some at one of their bases and as we were watching
it then zoomed to a distant location at an incredible speed
it might have been carried by an airplane they have
airplanes it had to be it was moving in a straight line on
the radar yes any form of ground transport would have been
affected by the terrain only an airplane could pull that off
but where did it land we didn't see it there at the masala
dig site rosetta would know let me ask her rosetta are we
advanced enough for planes oh my god rosetta i want to drive
a plane why don't you look chipper that depends on your next
answer are you saying you want my help i won't ask you to
fight I just want to know where the forest land armies
airplane is this one singular airplane the airplane okay, we
only have one
You tell there's only one when they're like the airplane not
the airplanes
Just one singular plane we have five 500,000 tanks I'll do
whatever it takes to stop bread I want to fly the airplane
once we get it Soon there'll be zero airplane Now that you
mention it, I've never gotten a pilot an airplane before
Even the old man wants to give it a spin Oh no, guys, I
think there might be zero planes soon No, I'll do what I can
to distract them from the ground with my tank unit In that
case.
Yeah, but that's in Sandland.
Even in Forestland, there's one plane.
That's what I'm saying.
The king might have outlawed planes in Sandland, but why
does the Forestland only have one?
I'm used to not having things easy.
Whoa.
No, you're supposed to be a Romaine Rosetta.
all right let's see yeah this way we had to go to
all right we have to go to what the fuck why how am i on the
bike okay we gotta go to back to forest land we go
all right i found us a place to camp yeah i found it let me
get up there all right i need to figure out how to get up
I'm gonna assume it's this way
Oh my god how the fuck Sumas like up like that Alright time
to get on the bike Alright If I go from here This should
lead to me to the mountain Right?
Yeah it does Alright Wow This place is overflowing with
creatures you'd never Just one rock.
All right.
Okay, just a rock.
Oh, there's new results in a different ecosystem.
All right.
Wait, there's bees?
They have bees?
Oh, shit.
Sorry, I'm shooting the wrong way.
What the fuck?
Oh, my God, they do have bees.
I get honey from this.
Well, I don't know about that.
Where's the queen?
Not the bees.
The bees!
Wait, but where's the queen then?
I don't see no queen.
Okay, we go this way.
Oh, that's the Omega Raptor.
Not as cool as the Alpha Raptors.
Is this this way?
I'm a little lost.
How do we get up there?
Here?
Oh, there's more bees.
How do we get up, though?
Is there, like, a way up?
Oh, no, there's loot, though.
Alright, nice.
We got boosters.
I feel like it's definitely not from this way, so we're
gonna drop down.
Maybe from around here.
Maybe it's here?
Oh my god I'm lost I'm so lost How the fuck Do you oh my god
Okay clearly that wasn't High ground Oh What the fuck Not
again Not again Wait where did Where did what the hell Where
did these guys come from Is it here Does this go up?
This has to go up.
I think it's here.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we did it.
We figured it out, guys.
We figured...
Oh!
Bush!
Are you...
Okay.
All right.
The bush got me, chat.
The fucking bush got me.
All right.
We're doing it.
It's got me.
Damn bush Alright, up we go Wee That one bush This bike
managed to run Past raptors and Mechs Except for that one
Mech Except No, he's serious I have to do that again I found
us a place to camp Oh my god I had to I have to do this
again.
Are you serious?
I don't remember how I got there.
How the fuck?
Okay.
How did I get there?
Oh, okay, it's this way.
Me.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
I have to ride my bike all over again.
So, I mean, I don't have the honey as well.
I think they took my honey, too.
No!
I killed those bees for a while.
nothing.
Oh.
You can see it from far away.
Oh, okay.
I want to...
I still want to grab.
Alright.
Not the honey.
You know what?
These don't really matter anyway.
I think it was like from here, right?
How do we...
How do we do this again?
I don't remember.
Oh, it's this way.
It's this way, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's from here.
They took my way.
I can't believe it.
Got cooked by a honeybee.
Sick vegetation makes for easy ambushes.
Whoa!
Okay, this time.
We're okay this time.
I'm not lost this time, guys.
I figured it out.
That's certainly something to keep in mind when in the
jungle.
Okay, I'm gonna make sure I have my nitro boost.
My nitro boost.
ready oh shit okay that's fine my bike is okay it's okay
it's just a little injured he he punched see that's what i
was saying he literally punched my bike but that does
nothing like that's so bullshit he punched my bike but i'm
still on it but a bush
diversion will help us this time the bush was our line so we
smash our way through head on isn't that a bit reckless even
for us please no stealth please go ahead and sneak in if
you're chicken i will us guys are going through the front
right oh
cowards pussies I don't need a sneak in.
I ain't no coward.
I have a tank.
Oh, they did it.
Oh, wait, no, I did it.
I'm a distraction.
I can do this.
Too scared to face me, huh?
The bug man.
There's more?
Like one measly insect man's gonna stop me There's more
Maybe Anne had the right idea Okay, please, please tell me I
can summon my tank Oh, thank god Oh my god Alright, Hanta,
thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you So here
you are, poetry No, I'm not chicken That's different Okay,
nice There's different types of birds.
No!
No, they kicked me off.
You're not allowed to drive.
Are you...
Are you serious?
They did not see the tank.
They did not see the giant tank.
That's okay.
All right.
They didn't see the giant fucking tank.
So now I have to do a stealth mission.
okay okay anybody here my Jesus they can't see me if I'm no
they can look up it's not fair why can they look up wait
where am I oh I've made it here I got a checkpoint okay nice
I got a checkpoint guys no I don't know where to go there's
no yellow here we go okay boom what do I do when there's no
yellow
oh what do I do there's no yellow anywhere look is he gonna
turn around oh whoa Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay.
I'm doing it my way.
Whoa, what the fuck?
How do I get across from there?
Wait, what?
Okay, I need to, like, figure this out, guys.
Oh, that's...
get through the poles?
No, that's not it.
Okay, now I'm a little lost.
Guys, why?
How do I get there?
There's so many people.
Oh my god, there's so many people.
The tank can see me too?
That should be illegal.
There's yellow paint there.
Why do I get through that yellow paint?
Okay.
I'm gonna scare him.
Alright.
How do I scare the tank, guys?
How do I scare the tank?
The ladder.
I see the ladder.
I'm improvising right now.
I don't know how to actually do this.
Okay.
You scare him.
then we climb we climb the ladder's yellow now how do i get
across what the fuck
i'm so confused how how how wait how
there's an open window oh that's how wait but like this is
just loot that's just loot that's not that's not how that's
just loot oh there it's over there it's at the back okay we
got it We got it.
We don't need loot anymore guys.
We don't need loot.
We're here for the plane.
That's enough loot for me.
So this is an airplane.
I guess.
You haven't even seen the plane before.
Sorry for the wait.
There's no plane to send them.
I got here first.
Slow pokes.
I got here before all of you actually.
Wait, you got caught?
No, I was searching the cells and the door locked closed
behind me.
Yeah, sure, Ann.
Sheesh.
Talk about...
That's what they all say.
So, let me get this ready.
How does she know how to fix planes?
She's never seen a plane before.
There's literally one plane.
How do I get on it?
Oh, Rao, get on the plane.
Oh my god, the insect men.
They let them integrate with the humans?
That is very like...
Because you gave us away with your yelling.
That's very progressive of them.
You already let the insect men integrate with the rest of
the humans.
There's a tank with wings.
Ha ha ha ha.
Prince!
Hold on tight, everyone!
But demons, yeah, like I was gonna say, races against
demons, but not the insects.
That's what I was thinking too.
Hector, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
As someone who studied aviation maintenance, that airplane
is a bit too chalky to be aerodynamically stable.
Those little wings could barely lift a damn thing.
Um, actually.
This is so exhilarating.
All right, we have insect men right now, and you're here
thinking this plane should not be flying
There's a little death star in the sky and you're worried
about this plane
I mean physics is physics okay But thank you actor
Oh, yeah, explain bees.
Oh, yeah, we have rockets.
Oh, it's pretty good.
This guy's an angel.
Like, is there, like, what, one singular angel?
Like, where are the other angels?
Where are the other angels that goes, like, Muriel?
It's time for bed.
Time's over.
No choice at all.
Target their front lines
Yeah, where is the angels to spank this Brad?
General Ari, heavy fire incoming What?
All troops evacuate!
Sorry, traffic jam.
Wait, we have a traffic jam!
Thank you for trusting your back to an enemy.
General.
Those that are gonna die now?
What the?
Those suckers, they cannot see that.
Well, well.
Looks like someone is trying to play hero.
Supreme Commander, someone's there.
It's Rosetta.
What is she?
Aboard!
Cease fire now!
It's too late!
We can't stop it from firing now!
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, aim up, aim up.
Aim up.
Where is it going to hit now?
Damn.
Fuck the animals that live there.
That was suck if anyone lives there.
I knew that you would.
What were you?
He blew up Spino.
Arrested, please, Cliff Land.
It's not over yet.
We need to keep the diversion going.
Beelzebub and the other should be en route to Garum as we
speak.
Can we really be mad at that?
Our sensors are picking up something.
It's thermal signature.
It matches that of our own high-speed plane.
plane the resistance must have hijacked it quick turn this
thing around we're going to swap this fly we got spotted
they'll shoot us full of holes in no time no shoot we got
spotted
oh thank god I just have to go up and down oh this is easy
oh wait did i hurt myself sorry this is easy okay now now
it's easy guys guys this is harder than it looks but oh shit
but to me it looked it's easy to me it's easy guys just say
what why was there a hole okay there should not be a hole if
i can't go through it
This is on you guys for putting me on the wheel.
You did not have to give me the wheel.
Oh.
Do I have guns?
How?
Whoa!
Just go.
Just go up and down.
That's it.
out this is how you dodge easy wait that's more than one
plane i thought they had one singular plane there's more all
right it lied to me
oh my god i can't believe it there was more than one plane
what the is this what the How?!
Oh, no!
Oh!
I did it.
You Claude!
No, Toho, my one weakness!
Toho!
You can't.
The cannon needs time to reload.
Not Toho.
Ready the cannon.
I don't care if it's not a max power yet.
Just kill that fiend Oh god, oh god.
Oh, this is awkward.
No, no more trouble I can't see No, that one hit.
Oh my god, that's so bullshit
Oh, no, I didn't do this all over again now.
Okay, guys, guys, this time, this time now.
Guys, I can figure this out.
Oh, God, guys, I can figure this out, guys.
Ooh.
Guys, see, I can do Toho.
I can 10 tries.
Okay.
All right.
No!
Okay, eight tries!
Eight tries!
Eight tries, guys!
Okay, I think the stereo...
We did it.
Insert credit.
Wait, what do I...
What do I do?
What do I...
what oh i did it i could what i barely registered what i was
supposed to do
i didn't even know what i did oh okay goodbye singular plane
that wasn't the only plane apparently i accidentally did the
quick time events i don't know how
madam madame adon prep me for this get off this contraption
without a plane it's a whole flying fortress surely there's
some escape pods basically we'll figure it all out later
don't worry so let's get right by last plane the last plane
in this army I'll handle this traitor myself I trust you
have no objections
whoa that was close all right we gotta find the commander
center it ends here all right we got this I believe in us
guys this is it now now we're at the final part guys this is
it I know I said that an hour ago and two hours ago but this
time this is the final area for real this has to be the
final area Now we're at the final stage.
This is it.
For real.
For real, guys.
This has to be the final area.
What?
I didn't hit that?
He, like, tanked it.
Holy shit.
That guy takes so much.
Come on, just let me shoot you one, Stereo.
there you go trust the final part part three oh god tank is
blocking here you holy shit that's a lot of mechas but yep
we only have like one plane
jesus yeah whoa don't worry i got you i'm gonna shoot
through this hole
Did I do it?
I did it.
No, the bridge.
Where'd I fucking go?
Oh, I have to go this way.
No, it's 2D time.
That's a lot of people.
Holy shit.
It breaks that, but not the other bridge?
Alright, it's time.
That's fucking right.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
You think I'm scared?
I will bring this tank up there.
I'm gonna bring this tank up there.
That's fucking right.
You think stairs is gonna fucking stop me?
That's right.
Stairs are not gonna stop me.
I'll walk up the stairs and bring my tank over.
Wait, what's this?
This is yellow.
All right.
Sorry, I got sidetracked by loot.
Oh, shit.
Forest Land Officer.
Who brings a tank?
I bring a tank.
Whoa!
This guy brought a tank, too.
Looks like we're in for a fight.
Oh, shit!
He hit me!
I'm flipping!
Ro!
Nice.
Okay, that's good.
Yeah, beat up the old man.
Don't beat up me.
Nice.
We have distraction.
Oh, wait.
I can't do this.
Nice.
We did it.
Yeah.
All right.
Now where do we go?
Oh, this way.
Am I supposed to shoot?
Ooh, this has to be foreshadowing.
Because, like, where am I supposed to shoot for this?
That's a foreshadow for something, I'm pretty sure.
I must have to do that late at another time.
Woo!
It's okay, I can run faster.
What's this?
What do you mean, I have to place?
Oh!
You're bad guys first.
No!
Oh my god!
I have to use my hands!
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I can't bring a tank.
That's so fucked up.
It wouldn't let me bring a tank to the fight.
What?
Oh.
Wait.
What?
What am I supposed to go then?
Am I supposed to beat you up first?
Oh, no.
It's okay.
Oh, I have to press a button.
Hey, that container moved.
Alright, that makes a lot more sense.
That actually makes a lot of sense now.
This way.
Okay.
oh my god he's me he's me he knows wait what then what ready
button mash huh they're not did i not do it oh there's more
than one oh did i do it now i can get over the container i
did it
buddy mashing time no guys it's okay there is a water bottle
at the next stop i believe i can make it oh there's loot too
nice wait but where does this go oh this is where we're
supposed to go i didn't realize that door is locked Anyway,
this is where we're supposed to go.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, gosh.
Oh, shit.
No, I can't drink water.
Whoa.
No.
Okay, I have to use my arms.
So far, so good.
All right, I used my arms.
Oh, thank God, water.
Oh.
All this rain in the world.
Oh, I knew it.
I knew the backside would have loot.
I could feel it.
Oh, my good.
Now I can bring my tank.
That's right.
You guys thought it's over.
You guys thought you couldn't get over here.
I brought the tank back.
Oh, is this it?
Is this what it's for?
Wait, you brought me off the thing.
No!
Get over here.
oh my god stop he's walking back he's floating backwards so
slow it's messing me up nice my three xp that's what i need
it is the aquarium causing this okay oh it could do so much
good put to better uses Oh my gosh.
We could have all the electricity and power in the world.
Is it here?
Oh.
Just fall straight down.
Okay.
All right.
I'm okay.
At least it being 2D, it's easier to destroy these bots.
All right.
Nice.
There's so much electricity.
Electricity fields here.
Bye.
Oh, I almost...
I thought I couldn't get that.
Alright, down I go.
Down I go.
Yay!
Ooh, tank time.
Alright.
What the fuck?
What are these guys trying to do?
This is not your fight!
Oh, fuck!
Okay, uh...
Did I do it?
Did I hit them?
I did.
Okay, nice.
I mean, Okay, get away.
This is not your fight.
Leave.
This is a tank fight.
You're not a tank.
Right down I go.
God, there's so much protection.
Looks like I can get on and keep going.
Okay.
And off we go.
Luke.
Yeah, Luke.
Luke that I'm not going to use because we're finally at the
final part of the game.
point in getting loot post you guys know i'm not gonna do
post game right but don't you think about the post game the
post what a game is finished when the game hits the credits
tanks here we go they're coming after us with everything
they've got okay we gotta make sure we repair we must be
getting close
all right oh that's the officer okay oh shit oh my god what
the fuck holy shit that guy does so much damage okay okay
we're just gonna do this don't you think about the post game
loot thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you Jesus
Christ That tank did so much damage Holy shit Goodbye
officer Oh this way Uh Thank you for the super chat Thank
you thank you Oh my god The tiny insect men Okay after
giving me like Tanks to fight they're gonna send these guys
Over Let's just How much are your damage are you going to
do?
Yeah, I thought so.
That's embarrassing.
That's embarrassing there.
There you go.
Oh, I gotta go this way.
Pew pew.
It's like actually swatting flies.
Oh my god.
what i know you're just chilling but like you too he's like
what did i do i was just taking in the scenery anymore no
more yeah i thought so oh wait that's you dragon ball bot
not fast enough though couldn't use your knife that's
fucking right is there another one oh shit there was like
he's level 24 that's not fair I can only be level 20 because
it's post game shit there you go the 9 XP he's literally
higher level than me and I still get 9 XP he brought a ink
but i know right that was easy let's ride it all the way to
the top okay is it working is there supposed to be like a
switch oh no there's loot there is okay let me grab the loot
first that i definitely don't need how do i ride the the
elevator Oh, okay, I had to press Y.
That tiny little button there that told me to press Y.
Oh, we're almost there.
20, 10.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, I'm fucking...
What the fuck?
Oh, my God!
Guys, he's burning me in the corner!
He's burning me in the corner!
Fuck.
Holy shit.
Oh, my God, it was like a gang fight.
Like, what?
Holy shit, that was...
Oh, my God, that was...
Oh, my God!
Just put me on a mirror, whoa!
Don't want to let me pass, huh?
Sorry, but I'm going over here.
You can't stop me.
Holy shit.
That was actually crazy.
How the fuck was that legal?
That did not feel legal at all He actually like stuffed me
into the corner of the room We can't lose this fight Let's
make sure that we're prepared Alright I think we're prepared
I think that's really all I'm gonna win till I get 100% guys
on the laser I'm like 20 i'm gonna wait until i get 100 on
the laser i'm gonna eat my sandwich Deadpool thank you the
super shot thank you thank you brave sir doki ran away she
bravely ran away when danger reared its ugly head she
bravely turned her tail it's not running away it's called
tactical retreat people do it
it's tactical okay i took a bite out of my sandwich.
I'm ready.
Okay, let's see.
Okay, reload, reload.
We're ready.
What the fuck?
Which one is it?
Oh, it's this guy again!
It's him!
Okay.
Okay, we can do this.
I- I- Okay.
I realized lasers don't work I figured out lasers do not
work on this guy
guys it was close guys it was so close though
it was so close guys it was bare We almost hit it Jesus how
might oh my god, I'm gonna fucking Try and get rid of all of
these first Holy shit, okay
You got him.
Oh, yeah, I totally got this guy.
I Totally do Okay, I'm just gonna use the explosive lasers
On like on like the things around me I feel like okay how
did I miss
yeah I'm gonna use it on these guys though
do I okay fuck you guys though you guys you guys need to you
guys need to leave you guys actually Oh, God.
Run.
Do your thing, run.
God, he's so tanky.
Oh, he's almost down.
He's almost down.
No!
It's fine.
It's just...
Oh, it's not fine!
You got him!
Yes, it's not fine.
Oh, why am I?
Oh, God.
Why did I drop down?
Bro, he's fucking pushing me down.
Nice, Biel.
Keep going.
This is not fair.
This is actually not fair.
Get this guy away from me.
Okay.
All right, we're okay.
We're okay.
We're working.
Keep on the offensive.
No, oh, no, I don't feel so good Wait, wait, that should
work.
That should work now.
That should work Because we're here I sigh.
Oh I still don't touch it.
How do I not touch it?
I don't understand.
shit.
This is not fair.
This is actually not fair.
Where is he?
One more hit.
No, except one more hits.
Oh, thank God.
It's over.
Oh, it's over.
okay we gotta like fix them we gotta make sure we have
enough repair kits here all right repair kit max okay we're
gonna put that here oh we did it we fucking did it i got him
down the elevator i go can't believe it our lasers work i
can't believe my laser didn't work okay loot that i don't oh
repair kit nice oh thank god we needed the repair kit oh and
water we always need water okay apparently not now though
nice fill up that water this looked like final boss area ish
Red?
I wasn't sure you'd make it here.
You getting the jitters now?
Do I look scared?
Guess not.
Like I said, you didn't quick travel to sock up for, oh,
never mind.
Okay, he's not final final boss because we had to fight
Muriel.
He's like second final boss.
But I made a promise to Rosetta.
He's not gonna have a change of heart gotta strike him down
It seems you understand me well I don't need to just you
can't change him he grew up in the old times where he were
people hated feelings
It must be because I lost it long ago.
What?
Nothing matters to me anymore Nothing except my my country
forest land and I swear I will exterminate any threat oh
shit oh my god he doesn't have a heart wait wait a minute oh
okay thank god I was gonna say oh this is bad or has that
old legend so rubbed off on you that you've discovered It's
bad that like whoa my god
I would say this is awkward if it was the mech fight because
we did not upgrade the mech we
Should have upgraded the mech guys
Guys I would I would bring the mech if the mech had any
upgrades but unfortunately I put all in on the tank I went
all in I went all in guys it's fine we just need to wait
until holy shit the bot is completely defenseless while it's
fire Oh my god I am trying my best the Okay, we have nitro
we have to reload though
Honestly, yeah, you should I'm actually doing really well.
Oh Okay, he missed nice No, no, okay No!
It's different.
It's actually not fair.
He can jump?
This is not a jump boy!
Oh my god, he can jump.
That's so messed up.
He can do a lot apparently.
Oh my god, he's almost done.
away from him to safety okay we're so close no i can't get
away from that okay we're fine so we don't need to use it
yet all right several more hits left what the no no no no no
i was so close that was so close that was actually so close
oh i would have been oh Oh my god.
Let's try to dodge this.
Oh no.
He's the only one.
Well, I did like more than 50%.
Why?
You have no heart?
You have no heart.
How are you alive?
How cruel?
that now even my body will be smashed apart by this a cursed
field no perhaps losing everything is exactly nanomachines
can you stop with the pity party bread how exactly do you
think we even made it this far it was Rosetta she told us
where the airplane was so she betrayed military secrets to
the enemy she was deeply conflicted over it but the reason
she ultimately did it was to stop you she wanted to save you
from the self-destructive spiral that's what you call
standing in the way of Garum's cannon to protect the enemy
yeah but you didn't kill her so you still have a heart what
is It was you she wanted to protect, not the Royal Army.
She was trying to save your soul.
She staked her life on it.
You're saying she?
That's what I choose to believe, at least.
I can't claim to truly know the heart of another person.
Reading minds is fiends' territory, after all.
Zeta has so much she wants to tell you.
So please stop your war crimes.
But after all I've done, how can I possibly face her now?
I mean, you're both murderers.
Not like one.
Like maybe one has killed more than the other, but you still
all killed civilians.
As her father.
So you're like on the equal...
I guess you guys are equal.
Aren't there things you want to tell your father?
Flick him.
War crime, boys.
Just flick him, you're right.
Just flick him.
Let's go beat that angel and get this over with.
Moonio is in the control.
The thing I'm very surprised by is that we forgive these two
very easily for it.
Like, yes, they're now on our side.
But, like, they're still murdered.
Like, I'm pretty sure the wives have told about how their
husbands were great here.
Heroes will not appreciate that.
Anime logic.
With the power of anime.
You shall be absolved of the thousands of people you
murdered.
Because you're hot.
As long as you look good.
doing it yeah i mean we forgave vegeta very easily for
everything because with the dragon balls we can wish them
back to life so commit as much murder as you want we'll just
wish them back to live
all right let's see
but vegeta's a homie That's different, Doki.
He's a homie.
All right, let's see.
All right, it's time.
It's time, Muriel.
Are you... Put your jacket up!
What the fuck, Muriel?
Put a shirt!
It's cold.
Are those chicken wings?
Behold!
The world, the divine one created.
what the fuck is that you put a shirt on now now it's not
just about it being cold now not just all you put a shirt on
what the fuck is wrong over your back they fell further and
further from grace oh he's a falling angel to bring the
humans back to the light and vanquish the demons
feel comfortable.
Orange, welcome to tomato.
It's low concern that you chose the chicken wings moment.
Just didn't fucking join the membership, but welcome.
I shouldn't have expected any better from a fiend.
Lucifer was exactly the same.
He wouldn't listen to a single word.
Just tore off my beautiful wings as I begged him not to.
Oh, he did that.
I'm not surprised a rotten apple like you hasn't fallen far
from the tree Like I care enough talking let's rumble No,
you want to fight you've got one let's settle this with just
no Round three
You impudent brat I'll teach you just how much stronger
angels are than thieves I Just please let me get the cake
Please This time for real Bro get over here The only
judgment here Get over here Okay let me I bought strength
serum for this I had a feeling I'm gonna have to do this
Okay and then health drink Alright health drink will be here
Uh, health, wait, did I, did I put the health drink on?
No, I didn't.
Put that here.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Alright, now I'm strong.
Oh, shit.
Get over here.
Now I'm strong.
I'm gonna pick the shit out of you.
Child!
Get your chicken nugget wings in here.
Oh, shit.
Man, I'm good.
Oh shit, I didn't see that.
That's not fair.
Here I go.
That's right.
See that again to my face!
Eh.
I ate some spinach.
That's fucking right, Munia!
I got some spinach in my ass!
Oh my god, Bubba!
Oh shit.
Oh shit, no.
No, not the bubble, not the bubble, not the bubble!
Not the bubble!
Oh shit, oh shit!
You can't turn around fast enough, you're on a roller.
I learned, guys.
Look at yourself.
You're supposed to put in your mouth It's like...
Things end up...
If you guys don't know...
If you put things in the butt absorbs faster.
If you guys didn't know about that.
But you are indeed strong.
Thing is...
what much stronger is he absorbing the queenium oh my god
he's owing what's
happening the equating energy he's owing out his own power I
can't tell but at this we will overdrive
What the fuck?
Holy shit!
He has wings now!
Okay, but how do you know that, dude?
I think it was super chat.
Come on, take it, take it, take it.
Jesus Christ.
Using a quenium to buff yourself in a fight is not fair.
B.O.
We need to use bots.
We can't beat them if you keep clinging to your pride.
Thank fucking God!
Oh my god, thank you.
I was...
What?
Okay, wait.
There we go.
Yeah.
Yeah!
What?
Okay.
I didn't realize I did that little damage.
Oh, he's on me.
He's on me.
He's looking at me.
Oh, he's looking at me.
I got a repair just in case.
okay nice thank god I can finally use my main power I do
like okay 2000 that's good this won't do what do you mean
this won't do I am trying my best I'm doing little poke
damage right now what is his weakness is Is it his bud?
This won't do.
Okay, nice.
Charging as max as I can.
Okay, 3000.
Yeah, no shit.
You're not losing your nerve, are you?
Oh, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
How did he get...
Bigger!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, bro!
Someone stop feeding him!
Who keeps feeding those giants?
Who keeps feeding him?
Oh god.
Someone needs to stop.
Oh, God.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
We got him.
He's down.
He's down, guys.
Oh, no.
He can't get up.
He can't.
He's stuck.
Oh, thank God.
Is he bugged?
Is he actually bot?
Oh my god, did it!
Wait!
So easy.
The hardest boss fight of my life.
Wait, no!
He unbucked himself!
No!
Oh my god, what?
What the fuck?
He turned back!
How did he do it?
Holy shit, he turned back.
Oh, God.
Maybe I shoot him in the butt.
Maybe that would work.
Okay.
Is he transforming again?
Oh, God.
I'm gonna...
Uh, Max.
Okay, I'm gonna do this.
Oh, he's back.
He's back.
he's big boy again he's big boy okay this is gonna take a
couple of years oh my god is he bigger oh he fell again he
can't get up this is it oh shit this is not fair oh my god
no he's gonna go back oh oh no no I'm not fast enough Jesus
Christ he's so tanky just shoot him in the dick all right
that's everybody's weakness it doesn't matter you're an
angel oh no okay bam all right guys we're almost there I can
feel it we We've made it so far!
Raul, get in there!
What?!
How did he sidestep again?
How did he keep...
How did he keep sidestepping?
I'm so unlucky.
I'm actually so unlucky.
He actually sidestepped step oh my it's so close is it looks
like fatigue is setting in he's getting tired he's getting
jeepy while he's reeling he's getting eepy guys oh god oh i
didn't get further away though i didn't get further away
though oh okay nice okay oh one hit one more hit quadruple
hit Last hit here!
This has to be it!
Yes!
This should be it!
This should be now phase three!
Did I do it?
Yes!
Are you okay?
Even a fiend is having an army.
Do you truly believe that what you are doing is right?
Where's the other angels?
The divine one is perfect.
And as his child, so am I.
Obviously, it is not even possible for me to do wrong.
But doesn't God say thou shall not dope up?
Is that in the commandments?
It's up to me.
Rumi, y'all, to guide you back to the...
Right with wings.
Oh.
I'm powerful
Oh my god, my shirt my cape said your prayers yet Whoa It's
badass
Like I'd let an angel Be more evil
Oh my god, can I still go?
Oh, he's gonna spill at the urn.
Just throw it up.
Oh!
What the fuck?
Isn't that...
We're two urns.
When's Lilith?
Mom!
Sister!
King Lucifer's inside of it!
We're talking about my dad here.
I'm sure he's fine.
Wait, if the urn falls and it cracks, then it freezes him.
So what do we do?
Get to the control room.
Mom's alive!
Okay, you handle that.
Thief and I will look for a good escape route.
Is this timed?
I hope it's not timed.
Because I need a fixed chat.
Are we gonna save chicken wings?
I can't believe it.
We're saving chicken wings.
You can tell he wants to save him.
We didn't save Epi, but we saved chicken wings!
It's changing his heart Sinners don't do a queen Thank you
for the super chat guys Thank you thank you Was everything I
believed in wrong all along That's what happens in war I
personally think you were very misguided
Jesus, he's used his cyborg string for that.
The whole place is falling apart before our eyes.
We're ascending too fast now.
It's no use.
I've lost all control over it.
The aquarium is going to explode any moment now.
Abandoned ship.
There's nothing else we can do.
Use the escape pods by the command center.
Go on.
Now!
Commander, we've been waiting.
It's here.
It's the Seen Pods.
So I need to tab and reload my chat real fast.
These are... Yeah, that's us!
It's fine.
Let every one of them onto an escape pod.
Yes, sir.
But, Commander, the pod only fits five.
Soldier, get out.
There's Goodbye, soldier.
There's five main characters.
I don't know what his problem is.
There's one guy with no name.
Don't worry.
I'm freed.
I'm afraid I can't allow that.
If anyone should stay.
Everyone that has a name, get in the same place.
pod.
I'll start with this.
I'll stay and see it through to the end.
Quit brooding and get in the pond.
Where's the soldier?
There's only three people there.
Don't trust the word of a fiend.
I do more than anything.
In there at the back.
Am I gonna save chicken wings?
Oh!
I am!
It's okay, just drink your serum!
Oh my god, this sucks because I actually am just limping.
I can't even walk faster.
Alright, chicken wings.
Time to pull you up!
Why?
Why do we need to save Munya?
He already sinned.
Just use your heels, bro.
I spent so much money.
Here, stand up.
Oh.
Shoot.
I still don't have my strength back.
you need a hand why are you here where's bread we made it
this far together why would we separate now so only the
soldier took the pot I mean I appreciate it yeah how are we
gonna get down how are we gonna get down you can take us
can't you just fly us all down there with four people it
might work with just chicken one wings and not to carry poor
mire people.
I can't fly.
What?
But you're a fiend.
Can't they all fly?
You're a half fiend.
Can you fly?
Oh, man.
That was a poor planning.
Oh, then what do we do?
Yeah, what do we do?
And?
And...
Wait.
Luckily, I've got just the thing.
Oh, I see.
They're the floaty tablets I got from the poochie.
Okay, everyone hold out your hands.
It's a little candy.
Once you swallow these, you'll be able to float for 10
seconds.
Damn, 10 whole seconds?
Whoa.
So make sure to take them right before you're about.
That's a lot of faith.
Just drop down until 10 seconds.
You know if you're too high, up um you won't even die before
you hit the floor you literally die from the heart attack
because of the pressure before you hit the floor before you
die from the death of the floor okay so all i'm saying is
that like scientifically uh that's not how it should work
well there she goes that's very fast or like yeah lack of
oxygen Beef, your turn.
Guys, I have a bucket of water.
Mythbusters Sandland.
Oh, hurry up.
Wait.
It's like Bureau Clock all over again.
Here we go.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
I'm a fiend.
I don't get heart attacks on this guy
What the fuck is that got I guess wait, but they don't have
goggles I've only got one floaty tablet left What do I do
not care hold on he can't swallow one while he's knocked out
Well, okay, guess I got I should have goggles
What the fuck is
it did that help me?
Dad?
Dad!
Were you able to get out of the jar on your own?
No.
As luck would have it, the urn smashed against a rock.
The bruh!
You saved me from a rough landing.
Oh, that was me.
Sister!
You're pink!
I knew it!
Whoa!
That... whoa!
That elf?
Whoa!
Prince!
You had us worried you were up there for so long!
You all made it safely!
I told you the tablets would work!
Those things didn't help us at all!
Even the timing ran is impossible!
We all chickened out and took the tablets too soon!
So they wore off when we were still high up!
But before we crashed, some strange power saved us!
It looks like your family actually came to our rescue.
Ah!
How come the sister doesn't have a tell?
Mom!
You must be...
My mom?
She'd never seen her mom before?
I thought Mooney helped killed you.
Like, she's the same person just pink.
There were two urns of ceiling.
I was in the other.
You really think some second-rate angel could have defeated
me without one of those?
Oh, I see.
Oh Damn You've grown up so much
Please stop My father He's fine Thank goodness So this Is
your daughter Lilith I guess we're all jelly King chat now
Well then thank you The super chat Thank you Grandpa Grandpa
Never refer to me by this undignified form of address again.
I am Lucifer, the king of demons.
What the fuck was she gonna say to you?
Your majesty?
Oh, but you're a princess too!
That?
Oh no, that's bread, never mind.
Queen Lillard and Princess Anne.
I deeply regret what I did 10 years ago.
I was wrong about fiends and harmed you and many others in
my ignorance.
the
people of our nation are the ones who deserve an apology you
should be saying this to them not me yeah as you speak to
all those wives that lost their husbands and all those
children that lost their fathers without complaint hmm any
punishments in that case how about i wipe
bread but mend your warmongering ways use your talents for
the pursuit of peace oh thank you your majesty peace the
very concept makes me feel ill get those tree-huggers what
shall we do with the angel yeah what shall we do with
chicken wings I will inform the archangels and have them
come pick him up he'll be in for it then serves him right
rain in sunlight you see this it's raining well I'll be
how's the rain the Aquanium at work the Aquanium it took 30
years but it's being used as the peachy intended finally by
the way human what was your name again oh welcome to mudland
it's row sir well round you've done no not what's said the
elzebub and thief's leader you're a credit to your species
if you like we have a place for you at demon village thank
you i'm honored but i don't intend to turn in my sheriff's
badge quite yet after all this you'll return to being a
humble sheriff I like you, Rao.
Here, have a treasure chest.
Dad?
I was wondering if I can play games for two hours a day now.
Maybe?
Don't push your luck.
Practicing your flying would be a far better use of your
time.
Right!
I thought you said you'd go fly!
Yay!
We did it!
Oh my god!
It is That's when you know we beat the game When the rainbow
comes on the screen Is there after credits?
Thank you, Toriyama-san Oh my god Is there an after credits,
guys?
Ooh, there's screenshots There is?
Okay, I'll wait until after credits Oh my god, we finally
did it, chat!
Dragon Woods, we beat our
Oh I'm so proud of us We stuck it through It took us a lot a
lot of time But it took us all the way until I got a new
skin suit And we finally beat it Oh What a wild ride that
was Oh that was great though I had a great time My very
first JRPG that I've ever finished Potter thank you for the
20 gifted ships Thank you I really appreciate it uh but like
honestly like i had a great time i really did i know like
some of the dungeons were a little bit slow like a bit
repetitive but i really did enjoy playing this game with all
you guys and like you know getting to connect with bandai
too because of sandland um it was such a great opportunity
and i'm really happy to be actually able to finish it uh for
you guys i've never like i said i've never finished a jrpg
before but this is like a mixture of action so like it made
me actually like i wasn't as like um i used to get really
bored with g rpgs in general because like uh i don't really
like the fighting mechanics for gpgs um because it's just a
preference for me so i'm really happy that like you know i
like the action in this and i really like the action
mechanics within this in sandland so it really did um make
it very much more playable for me and be able to take it to
the end um um but yeah i really like the animation like 3d
models too i liked how the 3d models really um emphasizes
toriyama's art style and how it was very well modeled and
very well animated for 3d uh because it looks 2d for a 3d
model which uh is like such an accomplishment to do in
general.
And what else do I want to say?
But I'm so happy to finish this game with you guys and get
to the ending!
Oh my god.
Fucking Chiku.
Oh my gosh.
I wish he put on a shirt.
I wish.
If only he...
I did not want to see him without the shirt.
I really did not like it when he took off his shirt,
It was very uncomfortable.
Yeah, the chicken wings are very curt.
They really were.
But yeah.
Oh, I don't know if I can just skip the credits.
So I'm just going to wait until it plays to the end.
It's been a ride.
It's been a wild, wild ride today.
A wild ride in the tank.
I'm gonna stretch Oh yeah I heard First Descendant came out
today Or was it yesterday?
How is it?
You think it's worth playing?
People said It's basically Korean It's a Korean developer
right?
Korean publishing?
It's basically Destiny But like Destiny 2 but But like Made
by Korean developers Um Um Yeah, because I heard it was like
Nexon.
But I saw people were trying to play it because they're
like...
Since it's like similar to Warframe slash Destiny 2.
I know it just came out today.
I don't know.
Free to play.
Okay.
It says free to play.
But you know damn well.
Like later.
There's a system in place in there that justifies the
freedom of play.
play it yeah quote-unquote on the free
um it has mixed reviews i guess i won't try it out then i
was like thinking if i should try out the first descendant
uh next week but um if it has mixed reviews then i won't
check it out um yeah the micro transactions and stuff i know
that's what i was thinking i was like wondering if i should
try it out because uh people were like yeah it's a next game
that's coming out next big game that's coming out to be fair
a lot of triple a games um i mean i mean i feel like next
one is considered triple a publisher because they have made
a lot of big games too but uh and that blind girl remained
blind forever oh yeah we never cured her oh yeah thank you
for the super chat thank you we never cured we never cured
the blind girl we the alpha raptor but we never came back to
cure
oops that's that's my bad it's my bad oh man oh yeah yeah
the whole dark and darker thing that happened yeah i didn't
end up playing dark and darker because when it came out a
lot of people gave mixed reviews about it because apparently
um even though it was like free to play and back on steam
the updates for it was not great i don't know they fixed it
i was like thinking about it but then i read the reviews and
people were like it's not it says free to play but you have
to pay because you don't keep your loot you don't keep your
loot if you're playing the free version you have to pay to
keep the loot or something or like to unlock stuff um that's
why people were like yeah it's free but it's bait that's why
i never checked it out because i know when i was like oh
week but then i read the reviews and people were like um
people were like oh yeah it's bait like um if you actually
really want to unlock more of the game you have to pay money
for it because like if you play the free version you don't
keep your loot at all after a run something like that yeah
um yeah you get the you know i mean i mean obviously i mean
that's the whole mechanic You get the loot if you can get
out, but like And you have to pay to have Another character.
Yeah, I saw that Too.
I saw that you have to pay to get another Character.
I just saw a lot of Like, a lot of like Complaints about it.
Because it went from positive Reviews when it came out to
like Negative to like, I don't know if it has Negative or
Mixed right now.
But I saw that I went From Positive because it never was
like Yay, it's back on Steam!
And then Straight to Negative After like one day.
and i was like reading some of the reviews i was like what
the happened the people were happy and then and i um now i
don't know i don't know if it's mixed now or like if it's
still negative
um uh you just buy if you don't if you like it's because
like people the thing is people don't like like baited you
know um if it's gonna be free because the when they dropped
it on steam they made it like it's free now so it baited a
lot of people and people hate getting baited you know people
hate it they because they feel like they got like you know
they got like scam type deal like you know it's free but
like oh you baited me into this so um so people were mad
because they're like just call it a demo then don't say it's
free to play um just call it a demo instead of free to play
because in the end all the actual uh all the actual like uh
game like game mechanics is locked behind a paywall so
people got really mad about it uh or a free trial so that's
why i got review bombed because everyone because like when
they released they announced dark and darker being back on
steam um during the summer fest or whatever uh during the
summer game fest they He just said it's back on Siemens free
to play.
They never said anything about it.
They never said anything about it being locked behind.
Like, have, like, certain mechanics being locked behind
Paywall.
So everyone was, like, this is fucked up!
And people hate getting baited.
Yeah, yeah.
If anything, people are very passionate when they get
misled.
It's mostly positive.
Now, that's good to know.
I think they might have, like, also apparently updated the
game to...
They updated the game to, like, to appease people.
Because I saw Shurefort playing Dark and Darker earlier,
too.
Because at first he was like, yeah, I'm not going to play it
yet.
Because apparently, he's like, yeah, it's not that great
So if he's playing it again, I assume that they updated it
all.
And so Rain fell on Sandland for the first time in decades,
bringing with it many changes.
Hey.
Grass down.
In Forestland, the people welcome the return of King Jam.
Sandland and Forestland signed an official peace treaty with
each other.
Why are you ashamed of being pink?
Normalizing relations and finally putting an end to their
long war.
Nice.
No, it's sad.
King Jam charged bread and Rosetta with repairing the rift
Between humans and demons to prevent further
misunderstandings Drop him He destroyed our home The angels
Back in the celestial world Must
for a thousand years Yeah
Bro that's so fucked up Why don't they give him his wings
back
Oh my god, it's a Dragon Ball card!
I couldn't ask for a smoother ride!
Prince, surely it has to be my turn to drive by now!
He's working for Amazon now!
Into the Bezo mines, you go!
It's time for the Amazon warehouses!
You guys never should be, honestly.
If it isn't Anne.
Well, what you doing around here then?
Just passing through.
wherever I like now.
I gotta see the world to become a world-class mechanic.
The world is not just said then.
And...
I'm headed off with the old man here to bring presents to
the Peachy.
Well, now, that sounds like fun.
By the way, what's with that bar?
Rao got it from Dad and it's brand new.
Can you even believe it?
No, I mean, what's wrong with it?
What?
Nothing.
Something smells funny.
Prince, there's smoke coming from the engine.
Oh no, not the car!
How's it Michael?
Yeah.
Wait, Bell's is me.
What did you do, Dragon?
He's just like me.
For real, for real.
You guys are thief and I'm Bezelbo.
Oh boy.
This thing's in bad shape.
Gonna need to take it to the garage in Spino to get it fixed
up.
Yeah, Spino is our next stop.
Hmm, I'll come with you.
What about seeing the world?
Oh, it's not like I'm in a hurry.
Pretty sure hanging around you guys will give my skills a
better workout than seeing the world could.
What?
They're literally just going to the peachy.
It's road trip time!
Yeah, save Sandland.
Let's go back to Spino
You never leave Spino We did it We finished the game Yippee
I'm so proud of us.
We fucking did it guys.
We finally beat Sandland.
All right, let's go back to Oh my god my gosh whoops sorry
chat broken oops i forgot to post the chat here too oh
whatever i'm gonna save the game even though i'm never
touching uh i never touched the game back after completing
it i still feel like i have to save it oh hell thank you
super chat thank you thank you you finished timeline while i
was at work do over at two minute two over start from the
beginning oh my god We're not we're never cute that girl's
gonna stay blind forever
Unfortunate to that girl she's gonna.
She's just gonna be blind forever
That's so fun.
I'm really happy our very first JRPG.
I don't know what series to start next week.
There's so many games I really I really want to play God of
War.
I really do want to try out God of War because I never
played God of War before It's so hard to pick I can now play
like any It's like, you know, when you can play any game you
want now It's just like, what do I play?
It's like when you have so many choices You don't know what
choice to make Type yeah But I'll think about it I don't
know if I start With like the very Or I could play the
reason why I haven't played Elden Ring yet Is because
everybody is playing Elden Ring Like everyone is playing
Elden Ring And like I feel like everyone's getting like
Elden Ring fatigue Like every corporate VTuber, every indie
VTuber, every flesh tuber, everybody is playing Elden Ring.
So I want to wait a little bit when things cool down a
little bit.
Because I feel like you've watched people play it fucking
kill the same boss 100 million times in the last two weeks
now.
So that's what I've been like.
All right, I'm going to wait until, like, you know, less
people.
It's like super oversaturated.
Yeah, it is super over.
uh saturated um uh so that's why i haven't touched yet but
definitely will in the future i promise you guys i mean it
was a charity goal so i'll definitely do it in the future
there's so many things i have to do in the future um but
yeah it was great i had a great time oh my gosh it's been
five i've been streaming five hours in so long how about fps
i want i want fps i want to try what is it called is it trip
pen uh let's see is it trip on tool i want to try that
apparently that game's really good i may try that game maybe
next next week that's the uh yeah maybe next week i'll try
that one that's something i've been thinking about too um is
it good is it really good i might do that next week actually
um if it's um if you guys think it's like worth it uh it has
of reviews i was looking through it uh i know it's a little
spooky so um so i don't know the only thing i'm worried
about is that it is a little spooky anyway all right i know
i'm gonna call it here guys uh because i do have a lot
behind the scenes work to do i really wish i could have
talked to you guys more but don't worry things are gonna
cool down soon i swear um after anime expo um things will
definitely cool down a lot more now so um and i'll be able
to actually hang out with you guys and have more like actual
zatzadon with all of you guys um post post game zatzadons
again and super chat readings um but thank you everybody i
hope you guys enjoyed my very first time finishing a jrpg we
should all be proud we stuck out we fucking did it guys we
we stuck it to the end because i know sideline was alive i'm
so happy for all your end to the last last playthrough of
Sandland we should all be proud of ourselves we all
accomplished something today glad something is a super chat
thank you thank you do you think any of us dragoons watch
anyone else sounds like someone's making excuses thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you no it's not an excuse
guys also I hope you guys enjoy the new emotes everybody I'm
slowly adding I'm slowly commissioning more and more emotes
now um to fill uh to fill up our slots so yeah anyway guys
as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and
move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for
me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next
time everybody uh bye everyone bye jp thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you we were here till the end you
were here bye guys bye